PRESENTING A BILL BUT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND WE WILL START TO OUR
HEARING TODAY -- FOR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE FOR THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR ON WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY
SIX WE HAVE A COMMITTEE TITLED
NONPROFITS AND STATE GOVERNMENTS.
A AND I WILL START THE HEARING
AND SAY THAT I I THINK EVERYONE
FOR JOINING US TODAY AS WE
EXPLORE THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
NONPROFITS AND STATE GOVERNMENT.
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR WAS FORM TO
INCREASE AWARENESS BY THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE ROLE THAT NON
PROFITS PLAY IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY.
MY GOAL FOR THIS COMMITTEE IS TO
COLLABORATE ON STRATEGIES
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS
ON THE INTERSECTION OF ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL WELL BEING FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
THE GOAL OF THIS HEARING IS TO
LOOK AT BEEN NEUTRAL PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN STATE GOVERNMENT AND NON
PROFITS IN PROVIDING CRITICAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS DISCUSSING
THE CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
MOVING FORWARD.
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE TRUSTED
INSTITUTIONS THAT EXISTS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE NEEDY
UNWINNABLE.
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE EXPRESS
COMMUNITY VALUES AND PROMOTE
SOCIAL CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTY THESE
NONPROFIT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COUNT ON OUR NON PROFITS EVERY
DAY.
THEY INCLUDE HOMELESS SHELTERS
CHILD CARE CENTERS FOOD BANKS
AND THEY RELY ON GOVERNMENT
FUNDING TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
THE STATE USES NONPROFITS AS
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERS TO
ENHANCE SERVICES AND FILL
IMPORTANT GAPS I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM OUR PANELISTS TODAY
AND WOULD INVITE THE FIRST PANEL --
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD WE HAVE
AYE CHEN NOT TO LOCASCIO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS ELIZABETH GONZALEZ
ASSISTANT CHIEF STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE OFFICER --
AUDITS DIVISION AND AND THE VEAL
BERNIE YEAH DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BUREAU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING I WILL GO AHEAD AND
HAVE YOU ALL I BEGIN I THINK
WE'RE GOING.
TO BEGIN WITH.
IS IT GONNA BE.
CHANDAN.
YES PERFECT.
A LITTLE BIT BUT THANK YOU HI A
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR SO
MUCH FOR INVITING US IN FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND
ESPECIALLY OF COURSE SIDE YOU
KNOW THIS SEC CHAIRMAN LIMON
THAT DOWN.
I HOW MUCH THE COMMITTEE AND YOU
YOURSELF HAVE DONE FOR NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY SO WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT AND I IN PARTICULAR THE
BILL THAT WE PASSED LAST YEAR
TOGETHER AB. TWENTY TWO FIFTY
TWO WHICH YOU CAN HEAR MORE
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT ALLOWING NON
PROFITS BETTER ACCESS FOR
APPLYING FOR STATE GRANTS -- SO
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY -- FITTING
TODAY THAT YOU'RE TAKING THIS
TIME TO DO A HEARING ON THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN GOVERNMENT
AND NON PROFITS BECAUSE IT THIS
IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT IN CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE FOURTH
LARGEST INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS THE NONPROFIT SECTOR --
AND GOVERNMENT AND IN FACT AS
YOU PROBABLY KNOW ONE IN EVERY
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA JOBS AT A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
THAT'S MORE JOBS AND THERE ARE
STATEWIDE IN CONSTRUCTION MORE
THAN REAL ESTATE MORE THAN AND
FINANCE.
IN ADDITION MAYBE MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE BRING FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS INTO CALIFORNIA
FROM OUT OF STATE AND A
COMBINATION OF FEDERAL MONEY --
GRANTS FROM OUT OF STATE
FOUNDATIONS AND INDIVIDUAL
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR PEOPLE THAT
DONATE MONEY TO THE MANY
NONPROFITS THAT HAVE GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP ROLES AS WELL AS FOR
THE WORK THEY DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO YOU KNOW WE NON PROFITS OF
COURSE HIDDEN IN PLAIN SIGHT
EVERYBODY KNOWS THEIR CHURCH
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE GIRL SCOUTS
THE UNIVERSITY THE MUSEUM THE
ANIMAL SHELTER.
FUEL FOOD BANK AND THE AND THE
WIKIPEDIA BUT THEY SELDOM THINK
OF ALL OF THESE AS SORT OF BEING
PART OF ONE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY.
SARCHIE POINT TODAY'S THIS
GOVERNMENT RELIES ON NON PROFITS
TO DELIVER SERVICES.
AS JUST ONE EXAMPLE ONE THIRD OF
ALL MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED BY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WE DON'T
DELIVER SERVICES AROUND THE
MARGINS WE ARE IN FACT AT THE
CORE OF THIS DELIVERY.
AND IN TURN NONPROFIT STATE
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE THE FUNDS
THAT MAKE THOSE SERVICES
POSSIBLE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR AS A WHOLE OF
30% OF OUR TOTAL REVENUE COMES
FROM ALL THE VARIOUS LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT PUT TOGETHER.
SO THIS GOVERNMENT NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIP ISN'T JUST KIND OF A
LITTLE DEAL IT'S LIKE A REALLY
BIG DEAL THAT'S AT THE CORE OF
HOW CALIFORNIA DELIVER SERVICES
TO ITS COMMUNITIES.
SO WHAT ARE THE LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT THAT FUND NON PROFITS
AND HOW DOES THE MONEY FLOW WELL
FIRST SOME FEDERAL MONEY GOES
DIRECTLY TO NON PROFITS FOR
EXAMPLE THROUGH HIDE. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THE DEPARTED MARK
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR AND
OTHERS.
SOME FEDERAL MONEY GOES TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH THEN
WE GRANT SOME OF IT TO NON
PROFITS.
CALIFORNIA ALSO USES THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND TO FUND SERVICES TO
NON PROFITS IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED STATE
AGENCIES AND SUB AGENCIES THAT
GIVE GRANTS AND CONTRACTS AND
NON PROFITS.
WE SHOULD MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
ALMOST ALL UNIVERSALLY FINDING
IS NOT MADE AS A GRANT TO AN
ORGANIZATION'S IT'S MADE FOR
DELIVERY OF SERVICES. FOR
EXAMPLE PAYMENT FOR PER HOUR FOR
THERAPY FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES.
PAYMENT FOR THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
TREATED FOR TB PAYMENT FOR THE
NUMBER OF BAD NIGHTS IN A WHAT
BATTERED WOMEN'S SHELTER OR THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM.
I AS WELL AS FOR EXAMPLE
PAYMENTS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WERE IN RESIDENTIAL
PLACES OR WHO ARE RECEIVING --
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
FISH AND WILDLIFE FUNDS
NONPROFITS AS PARTNERS AND FRESH
WATER PRESERVATION AND MARSHLAND
CLEAN UP CAL FIRE FUNDS
NONPROFITS AS PARTNERS AND FIRE
PREVENTION.
THE DEVELOP DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IN THE
NONPROFIT REGIONAL CENTERS FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
ARE SO INTIMATELY INTO INTER
TWINED -- THAT WOULD BE HARD TO
EVER PULL THEM APART I AM DEEP
THERE SO THEY WORK SO CLOSELY
TOGETHER IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS -- WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
PREPARING OUR SECOND ANNUAL A
SECOND I ANNUAL SECOND ECONOMIC
IMPACT REPORT IN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR WHICH WILL BE READY IN
THE FALL BUT WANT TO GIVE YOU
SOME SNEAK PREVIEW INFO.
US SO FIRST OUR GOVERNMENT FUNDS
DISTRIBUTED EVENLY AMONG THE
ABOUT THE STATE WELL OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS PROFOUND THIS
THIS DISPARITIES.
IF WE EXCLUDE FOR THE MOMENT
HOSPITALS AND UNIVERSITIES FOR
THE FROM THE EQUATION IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACIST DISTRICT TO US ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
HAS 11% OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION BUT ONLY 6% OF
GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
AND WHAT KINDS OF SERVICES TO
THESE NON PROFITS FUND ART SORRY
DO THESE FUNDS FUND -- WELL
ABOUT 80% OF GOVERNMENT REVENUES
GOES TO HUMAN SERVICES AND
HEALTH IN ONE KIND OR ANOTHER --
BUT IT GOES TO ALL KINDS OF
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL.
SO WHY DOES IT MAKE SENSE FOR
GOVERNMENT AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO FUND NON PROFITS TO
DO SERVICES RATHER THAN THAN
DELIVERING THEM DIRECTLY
THEMSELVES BUT HERE JUST A FEW
REASONS FIRSTOF ALL.
IN THE AREA OF CONTAGIOUS
DISEASES MANY PEOPLE WHO NEED
TESTING AND TREATMENT FOR
CONTAGIOUS DISEASES SUCH AS TB
AIDS AND HEPATITIS.
CAN BE REACHED BETTER BY THE NON
PROFITS IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
THEY DON'T THESE NONPROFITS
DON'T HAVE THE INTIMIDATING
STAMP OF GOVERNMENT THERE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY IN
TUNE WITH THE WITH THAT
COMMUNITIES.
AND THEIR PERCEIVED IS TRULY
FRIENDLY AND AND COMMUNITY BASED.
SECONDLY NONPROFITS ARE
INNOVATIVE AND SERVICES NOT JUST
DELIVERS OF SERVICE JUST AS ONE
EXAMPLE.
NOW THAT. TWENTY YEARS AGO OR
THIRTY YEARS AGO IT WASN'T
THOUGHT THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES COULD ATTEND
MAINSTREAM SCHOOLS COULD HAVE
MAINSTREAM JOBS ARE COULD VISIT
MAINSTREAM PARKS.
NOW WE KNOW THAT ALL THOSE
THINGS HAPPEN IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE NONPROFITS EXPERIMENTED
WITH AND ADVOCATED FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF SERVICES AND FOR A
DIFFERENT WAY OF THINKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
THIRD NONPROFITS CAN MOBILIZE
VOLUNTEERS RAISE MONEY AND OUR
NUMBER THAN GOVERNMENT.
THESE ARE ASPECTS OF SOMETIMES
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO DO
OUR WORK AND A MODESTLY LOWER
COST.
SO TO BRING THIS TO LIFE I WANT
TO TELL YOU ABOUT JUST ONE
NONPROFIT -- IN THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND NON PROFITS IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE PAID STAFF.
AND THAT IS TO HIT THE CENTER
FOR HUMAN SERVICES WHICH IS
LOCATED IN MODESTO A NONPROFIT
WITH MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED STAFF
PROVIDING AS RANGE OF SERVICES
THROUGHOUT STANISLAUS COUNTY.
AND THE NEXT TIME YOU DRIVE INTO
MODESTO YOU'LL SEE THEIR BIG
SIGN ON THEIR BUILDING BECAUSE
THE ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE AS YOU
DRIVE IN THEY SERVE MORE THAN.
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE INCLUDING
MOSTLY CHILDREN EVERY SINGLE
YEAR.
SO HOW DID THEY DO THIS WORK
WELL FIRST THEY USE PROP SIXTY
THREE THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT. FOR EARLY INTERVENTION WITH
TROUBLED FAMILIES THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES SEE SOME OF
THE CRUCIAL PARTNER AND FINDS
THEM AS THEY TRAFFIC AND SUPPORT
SUPPORT IN VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THEY HAVE A CASE MANAGER
EMBEDDED IN HIGH RISK JUVENILE
PROBATION THAT SUPPORTS GIRLS ON
PROBATION AND HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ISSUES.
THE BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS THROUGH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CRIME PREVENTION ACT
KNOWS THAT THIS WERE COULD NOT
BE DONE IF THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
FIND THE CENTER FOR HUMAN
SERVICES.
MODESTO CITY SCHOOLS PROVIDES
HIM PROVIDES FAMILY SERVICES
THROUGH THE CENTER FOR HUMAN
SERVICES AT ELEVEN DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
HIGH ABSENT SCHOOL FOR HAVE HIGH
ABSENTEE AND OTHER KINDS OF
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES.
THEY CAN'T STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS REFUGEES THROUGH CAL
NEW PROGRAM.
THROUGH SORRY THROUGH CAL NEW
FUNDING -- THE MODESTO CENTER
FOR HUMAN SERVICES ALSO RECEIVES
FUNDING FROM THE OFFICE OF CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION TO HELP.
THAT PROVIDES HOME VISITING
PROGRAM FOR FIRST TIME MOTHERS
WHO HAVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES
AND I'M SURE I LEFT OUT
SOMETHING THEY DO.
BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT ALL OF
THESE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES RELY
ON THE CENTER TO PROVIDE
SERVICES.
AND IN TURN THE CENTERS CLOSELY
CONNECTED WITH THE WITH THE
GOALS AND THE MECHANISMS AND THE
STRATEGIES THEIR GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS.
AS PART OF OUR SOON TO BE RESET
RESET RELEASED RESEARCH WE ALSO
CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF MORE THAN
TWELVE HUNDRED NONPROFIT LEADERS.
AND THEY GAVE US SOME IDEAS ON
WHAT WOULD HELP STRENGTHEN THEIR
PARTNERSHIP WITH GOVERNMENT.
PROBLEM NUMBER 160% OF NON
PROFITS TO RECEIVE FUNDING NOTE
THAT THEY DO NOT RECEIVE A
SUFFICIENT PAYMENTS TO COVER THE
FULL COST OF THE WORK THAT IS
BEING CONTRACTED.
FOR AN URBAN INSTITUTE REPORT
FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN SAYS THAT
TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA
NONPROFITS HAVE INDIRECT COSTS
RATES OF LESS THAN 10% WHICH WAS
REFLECTED ON OUR SURVEY IT WITH
THAT SHOWED 50% THAT SHOWED
FEDERAL COST RATES BE AN AVERAGE
OF NINE POINT 8%.
STATE RATES EIGHT POINT TWO AND
COUNTY AND CITY RATES 8%.
HOW 8% OVERHEAD MIGHT SOUND KIND
OF HIGH BUT WHEN YOU REMEMBER
THAT THE FOR PROFIT BUSINESSES
AND SERVICES AGENCIES?
USE AS A STANDARD 35% IN
OVERHEAD HE BREAKS YOU REALIZE
HOW LO THESE INDIRECT COSTS
RATES ARE.
IN THE FOR PROFIT WORLD LARGE
RETAILERS KNOW THEY HAVE A STAKE
IN HAVING STRONG SUPPLY CHAINS
THAT MEANS THEY HAVE TO PAY
THEIR SUPPLIERS FAIRLY SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT PRESSURED TO CUT
QUALITY OR UNDER PAY THEIR
WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA NON PROFITS ARE A KEY
PART OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN TO
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT AND
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT HAS A
HUGE STAKE IN MAINTAINING A
STRONG ECOSYSTEM IN THE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY.
SECOND PROBLEM NONPROFITS
FREQUENTLY REPORT THAT PAYMENT
RATES CAN GO UNCHANGED FOR MORE
THAN TEN YEARS.
IN AREAS SUCH AS THE
REIMBURSEMENT COSTS FOR MEALS
DELIVERED TO ISOLATED SENIORS
ARE FOR TESTING AND PHYSICAL
THERAPY FOR PEACE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
AS THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
GOES UP THESE RATES -- SIMPLY
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO GO ON
NONPROFITS WORK HARD AT RAISING
PRIVATE MONEY FROM FOUNDATIONS
AND FROM INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE UP
THE GAP. ONE OF THE LIMITATIONS
OF THAT HOWEVER IS IT MAKES IT
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO GROW.
THEIR GOVERNMENT AGENCY COULD BE
SAYING WE WANT A DOUBLE THE
FUNDING WE GIVE YOU SO THAT YOU
CAN DOUBLE THE SERVICES YOU'RE
PROVIDING.
BUT THE NONPROFIT IS SAYING BUT
WE HAVE TO RAISE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO DO
THIS WORK TO CLOSE THAT GAP.
I'M NOT SURE WE CAN RAISE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO IN EFFECT THE ISSUE OF UNDER
PAYMENT AND LOW AND OTHER NO
TURN OVER AND RATES.
MEANS IT MAKES IT HARDER FOR ALL
OF US TO GROW SERVICES ONE MASS
PROBLEM I WANT TO MENTION IS
THAT 44% OF NONPROFIT SAY THAT
LATE PAYMENTS ARE EITHER A
MODERATE OR SEVERE PROGRAM.
PROBLEM IN FACT -- COMMUNITY NON
PROFITS ARE IN EFFECT LOANING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT TO STATE
GOVERNMENT.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE JUST AS
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT HAS A
STAKE IN ENSURING THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN THE
TECHNOLOGY OR HEALTHY AND STRONG.
GOVERNMENT ALSO HAS A STAKE IN
ENSURING THAT THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY IS A HEALTHY KIDS
HEALTHY AND ABLE TO PARTNER WELL
WITH GOVERNMENT.
SO THIS PARTNERSHIP.
REST IS WHERE THE LIVES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES RESTS WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE IT
STRONGER.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US TODAY.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
SHARING ALL OF THAT REALLY GOOD
INFORMATION THE DATA I THINK
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING -- I'M A LITTLE BIT
GONZALEZ -- SYSTEM TO PUT THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
DIVISION ABOUT IT THEN THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR HAVING.
ME HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
CONTROLLERS ROLE AND ASSISTING
THE NONPROFITS AND GETTING THEIR
FUNDING YOU KNOW THERE -- CLAIMS
PAID SUCH AS AND TENER GENERAL
OVERVIEW THE STATE COMPTROLLER
AND HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
AUDIT -- CLAIMS THAT ARE
RECEIVED FOR A PAYMENT WE LOOK
FOR THE LEGALITY VALIDITY AND
PROPRIETY OF THE LAME -- WE
PROCESS CLAIMS VIA PAPER CLAIMS
SCHEDULES AS WELL AS VIA
DISCOUNT VOUCHERS -- PAPER
CLAIMS SCHEDULES WEEKEND WE
RECEIVE UP TO LIKE NINETY NINE
PAY EASE AND ONE CLAIM SCHEDULED
VOUCHERS ARE NOW ONE PAGE EIGHTY
PROVIDES HER -- WHAT WE LOOK FOR
AS FAR AS IN THE NON PROFITS --
WE CAN ONLY GO TO THE CONTRACT
OR GRANT THAT IS PROVIDED TO US
AHEAD OF A MAKING ANY PAYMENTS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE OUGHT IT TOO
WE WE LOOK.
FOR YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT --
THE WHAT'S BEING REQUESTED IS IN
THERE SO I KNOW WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT AND DIRECT -- COSTS
BETWEEN -- A CONCERN.
AS FAR AS AS LONG AS IT'S
ALLOWED IN THE CONTRACTOR IN THE
GRANT AGREEMENT WE WILL --
APPROVE THAT.
YEAH AND THEN -- WE ALSO THE NON
FOR PROFITS THEY FALL INTO THE
PUMP PAYMENT ACT.
WHICH ALLOWS OF WHAT WE HAVE TO
APPROVE A PAYMENT THE STATE HAS
TO APPROVE A VALID.
PAYMENT AND FORTY FIVE DAYS AND
GENERALLY THE DEPARTMENT HAS
THIRTY DAYS AND THEN WE AT THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAVE
FIFTEEN DAYS. TO AUDIT THE
PAYMENT AND IF IT'S A VALID
PAYMENT -- ISSUE THE WARRANT --
AS FAR I MEAN THAT'S KIND IN
GENERAL WHAT WE DO THIS IN THE
AUDIT SHOP FOR NONPROFIT SO IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO OUR NEXT PRESENTER
I'M TRYING TO PICK UP THE CLOSER.
TO THEIR HELP.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PRESENTATION.
GREAT WELL MY NAME IS ANNABELLE
FUNNY I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BUREAU AT
THE STATE LIBRARY -- AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING US HERE --
SO -- WE'RE PLEASED TO BE ABLE
TO TALK ABOUT A NEW PROJECT THAT
IS -- HAPPENING BECAUSE OF YOU
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMPLY
MEMBER -- SO IT IS ONE WEBSITE
FOR ALL STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES SO -- THAT
WAS A BILL OF PASSED LAST YEAR
HI YOUR BILL AB -- TWENTY TWO
FIFTY TWO WHICH IS THE GRANT
INFORMATION ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND SO AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY TWO IS GOING.
TO RATE FOR THE FIRST TIME A
SINGLE PLACE WHERE ANYONE WHO'S
INTERESTED IN SEEKING A GRANT
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
WILL BE ABLE TO GO ON THE
WEBSITE AND SEE ALL THE GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES AT ANY GIVEN TIME
SO -- THIS.
IS A STATUTORILY REQUIRED BY
JULY -- ONE TWENTY TWENTY THE
STATE LIBRARY HAS STARTED THIS
WORK -- TO TO STARTING -- THE
WORK OF LOOKING INTO THE NEEDS
OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
CONSTITUENCIES -- EACH STATE
AGENCY IS GOING TO PROVIDE THE
LIBRARY WITH A SET OF DATA
ELEMENTS ON THEIR NUMBER LAID
OUT IN THE LEGISLATION.
AND A NUMBER THAT WE THINK THAT
WILL SERVE IMPLICITLY FALL FROM
THOSE THAT WILL NEED IN ORDER TO
DO SOME OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND OTHER THINGS --
AND AS WE TALK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
SUCH AS COUNT ON PROFITS --
WE'VE ALSO -- MET -- SO WE MET
RECENTLY WITH THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS -- WE MAD WITH KOBE IS
TO TRY TO AND TALK TO FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF SOME OF THE
BUSINESSES TO APPLY FOR GRANTS.
AND JUST STARTING TO GET A BASIC
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS NEED AND WANT
AND THE WEBSITE TO MAKE IT AS
USEFUL TO THEM AS POSSIBLE WHEN
PEOPLE ARE APPLYING FOR GRANTS --
AND THEN WE'RE ALSO I'M IN THE
PROCESS OF MEETING WITH LOTS AND
LOTS OF STATE DEPARTMENTS TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR PROCESS NOW --
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS -- BUT
THAT THEY NEED SO THAT WE CAN
EFFECTIVELY AND QUICKLY TRANSFER
INFORMATION OVER -- AND
ELECTRONICALLY THERE WILL BE NO
PAPER -- SO THAT WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW THE INFORMATION WILL
COME OVER BUT WE DO KNOW IT WILL
BE.
IT WILL BE IN OUGHT SOME
SOMETHING THAT IS A AT LEAST A
TO AUTOMATED OPTIONS AND THEN --
POTENTIALLY A FORM OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BUT WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THAT -- SO AS
THE WILL BE PUBLISHING AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON THE EFFECTIVENESS --
IN JULY WHEN I JAN ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT WE AT THIS POINT --
LOOKING HOW WE CAN BUILD INTO
THE WEBSITE -- A LOT OF THE DATA
THAT'S REQUIRED IN THE ANNUAL
REPORT SO THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT AND REAL TIME -- IS A
LOT OF THE A LOT OF THE
INFORMATION IN YOUR REPORT IN
TERMS OF HOW MANY FOLKS ARE
VISITING WHERE THEY GOING ALL OF
THAT WE CAN BUILD THAT INTO THE
ANALYTICS SO THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT TILL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO SEE THAT --
SO ONE THING WE'VE BEEN REALLY
CLEAR ABOUT WHEN WE'VE BEEN
TALKING -- WITH DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS IS THAT --
PARTICULARLY FOR THE STATE
AGENCY SIDE MAKING SURE TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THIS DOESN'T
CHANGE -- THEIR APPLICATION
PROCESS IT DOESN'T WE ARE NOT
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A GRANTS
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM FOR THE STATE
BUT IT IS WHAT IS CHANGING IS
HOW WE PUBLICIZE GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE TO
MAKE THAT INFORMATION CLEARER
AND MORE STANDARDIZED -- SO I AS
I MENTIONED RIGHT NOW WE'RE
DOING INITIAL MEETINGS WITH USER
GROUPS -- WE HAVE AS STARTING
JULY FIRST WE WILL HAVE A BUDGET
WHICH IS REALLY EXCITING AND
ACTUALLY ARE -- AT NEW PROJECT
MANAGERS GONNA START ON JULY ONE
IS HERE HER NAME IS GIOVANNI
BOTH FOR ALAN KEYES BACK THERE --
AND WE WILL BRING HER BY TO MEET
YOU VERY SOON.
I SO WE ARE.
WORKING ON CREATING A PROJECT
PLAN -- AND WILL START MEETING
WITH EVERYONE VERY SOON -- SO --
THAT WE HOPE TO HAVE AN EARLY
PROTOTYPE -- THAT DEVELOPED SO
THAT WE'RE GOING WITH THE DATA
FROM SOME TEST DEPARTMENTS SO
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SEE EARLY ON WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE INTEGRATING
AND IMPROVING ON BUT WE DO PLAN
ON USING A HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN
PROCESS AND REALLY MAKING SURE.
THAT THIS MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
INTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS -- AND
THAT CREATES A REALLY GREAT
PRODUCT THAT SERVES THE PURPOSE
OF THE LEGISLATION -- SO WE'D
LOVE TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS --
AND THAT THAT'S THAT'S THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND SO MAYBE A STAR
ACOSTA GO BACKWARDS IN TERMS OF
THE ORDER BUT I'LL I'LL START.
HERE -- WITH AND IF IT'S OKAY
JUST.
THIS IS THE YOU KNOW AS I TALK
TO PEOPLE THIS IS STILL
SOMETHING THAT COMES THAT PEOPLE
REALLY ARE LOOKING AT PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR JUST A RESOURCE TO
IDENTIFY IT FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES.
I THINK IN LIGHT BECAUSE OF WHAT
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MENTIONED BY JAN -- IN TERMS OF
THE NEED -- YOU KNOW I I HEARD
THAT TO AND THERE'S NO WAY THAT
YOU KNOW THAT -- A NONPROFIT CAN
GROW IF THEY'RE UNDERPAID --
THAT THE YOU KNOW LATE PAYMENTS
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE NONPROFIT --
AND SO FUNDING ALL BECOMES A BIG
NEED BUT HOW DOES THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY.
ANTICIPATE -- THEY WILL PARTNER
WITH ASSOCIATIONS LIKE HELL
NONPROFITS OR OTHERS YOU KNOW
ASSOCIATIONS ARE GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND PERHAPS IT'S REALLY
EARLY.
IN THE PROCESS TO IDENTIFY THIS
BUT I MEAN I JUST DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY KIND OF LARGER --
BROADER CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
PARTNERSHIP COULD BE LIKE
BESIDES THE PHYSICAL -- AND
TECHNICAL PART OF GETTING ALL
THE INFORMATION IN AND HAVING
PEOPLE CLICK ON THE WEBSITE THAT
MAKES SENSE YEAH WELL I MEAN I
THINK RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON IS REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND SO THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S SO CAL NONPROFITS
PUT.
TOGETHER AIDS FROM A TASK FORCE
OF DIFFERENT NONPROFITS WHO THEY
THOUGHT WERE REPRESENTATIVE IN
SORT OF SIZE AND GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATION AND WE DID A VIDEO
CONFERENCE WITH THEM I GUESS NOW
ABOUT.
EVERY TWO MONTHS AGO -- TO START
WITH THEM ON UNDERSTANDING WHAT
WERE THE BARRIERS THEY WERE
FACING -- AND WHAT WERE THE
THINGS THEY REALLY WANTED TO SET
WE THEY REALLY WANTED TO SEE OUT
OF THIS FINISHED PRODUCT SO THAT
IT WOULD MEET THEIR NEEDS -- AND
SO THAT'S I THINK WE'RE WE'VE
REALLY BEEN STARTING IS BUILDING
THAT RELATIONSHIP AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT ARE THE
THINGS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS WE CAN GET DONE BY JULY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AND WHAT ARE
WHAT ARE THE LONG WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE LONG TERM.
GOALS THAT WE KNOW AND THERE MAY
BE FIRST SIR I KNOW CHEN I'VE
HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
DATA THAT THEY'RE REALLY
INTERESTED IN GETTING WE DON'T
KNOW IF PEOPLE COLLECT THAT
RIGHT NOW -- AND SO THEN HOW DO
WE IDENTIFY THAT AND THEN
POTENTIALLY BUILD ON THE PROCESS
OF IS THAT IS THAT DATA THAT WE
WANT TO START COLLECTING -- TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT MORE
AVAILABLE SO -- DOES THAT THAT
IS YOUR QUESTION YEAH IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO TO SOME EXTENT GREAT
OKAY THANK YOU.
AND THE FOR THE AUDITOR ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT YET YOU
DESCRIBED IT IS THE PROCESS A
KIND OF COLLECTING INFORMATION
AND ASSESSING IT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR HOW TO STRENGTHEN.
THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN.
AS THE STATE AND THE NON PROFITS --
JUST.
GENERALLY SPEAKING I MEAN I KNOW
THAT THEIR ROLE IS TO REALLY
LOOK AT ENSURING THAT COMPLIANCE
IN THAT ENSURING -- YOU KNOW BUT
I AM GET AT AND MAYBE I'M WRONG
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT WHEN YOU
SEE.
THE PROCESS.
WHEN YOU IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
WORKING PERHAPS YOU MIGHT HAVE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ON THINGS
THAT CAN STRENGTHEN THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN GOVERNMENT
AND NONPROFIT -- AS FAR AS FOR
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
BECAUSE THERE IS THE ROLE FROM
THE THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS THE
ROLE BECAUSE THEY THEY'RE
PROVIDING THE CLAIM SCHEDULED TO
US -- AND SO.
I WOULD SAY IT'S MORE ON THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE THAT
THE CLAIM SCHEDULE PROVIDE IT TO
US IS ACCURATE.
AND AS FOLLOWS THE THE CONTRACTS
IN THE GRANT AGREEMENT BECAUSE
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT WE THOUGHT
IT.
TOO WE'RE NOT SETTING POLICY OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT WE'RE JUST
LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PAYMENTS THAT WERE PAIN -- FALL
UNDER THAT GRANT AGREEMENT OR
THE CONTRACT.
AND ARE THERE ANYTHING FROM.
FROM YOUR ANALYSIS OF WHETHER
THE PAYMENTS FOLLOW THE GRANT
CONTRACTS ARE.
FROM THAT ANALYSIS ARE THERE ANY
TAKE AWAYS THAT YOU THINK COULD
BE HELPFUL FOR LEGISLATIVE BODY.
TO THINK ABOUT -- AGAIN OR MAYBE
THEY WERE THE THE MAYBE A
RECOMMENDATION WAS NOT THE RIGHT
WORD BUT AT ANY TAKE AWAYS FROM
ELEMENTS THAT YOU SEE ARE THERE
ANY TRENDS OR PATTERNS THAT YOU
SEE.
THAT TEND TO BE -- THAT TEND TO
COME UP MORE OFTEN -- I WOULD.
I WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK AND
CHECK BUT THE STAFF THERE TO SEE
IF THERE'S A A TREND USUALLY
IT'S JUST INFORMATION THAT'S
MISSING THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
TO THEN OBTAIN AND PROVIDE IT
AND THEN WE SUBMIT THE CLAIM
SCHEDULE.
GREAT THANK YOU AND I AM SORRY.
I WOULD HAVE.
TO AGREE WITH THAT POINT THAT
THE IT THE THE ISSUES TEND TO
STEM FROM THE CONTRACT FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF HOW THE
CONTRACT IS WRITTEN.
I'M AND SECONDLY FROM HOW IT'S
PROCESSED WITHIN THE DEPARTMENTS
BY THE TIME IT GETS TO THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
ON THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM NOT
THE BOTTLE NECK I SHOULD SAY.
BACK WHEN I WAS A NONPROFIT CFO
I USED TO THREATEN ALL THE TIME
TO HAVE TO I WOULD SET UP A PUP
TENT -- AND ON THE IN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES UNTIL LATE WE WE GET
OUR PAYMENT SO THINGS HAVE
GOTTEN BETTER SINCE THEN WITH
THE PROBLEM PAYMENTS ACT BUT
IT'S A IT'S IT'S AT THE AGENCIES
IN THE FACT THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE ONE CONTACT FOR THE
AGENCIES THROUGH THE STATE
LIBRARY.
WELL I THINK ALSO EVENTUALLY
TURN INTO PARTNERHIPS AND
RELATIONSHIPS THAT CAN HELP
STREAMLINE THAT.
THANK YOU AND HAVE.
DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA OF HOW MANY
GRANT AGREEMENTS CAP OVERHEAD.
ALTHOUGH NO WE DON'T OKAY THAT'S
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES OF WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW OKAY WE DO KNOW WE
YOU KNOW WE CAN TRACK A
PARTICULAR BILL FOR EXAMPLE BUT
IN A AND CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR A
LOT OF STATE MONEY GOES TO
COUNTIES.
AND THE COUNTIES ACTUALLY OF THE
ONES THAT USE THE NON PROFITS
AND WRITE THE CONTRACTS AND SO
YOU CAN HAVE THE SAME
APPROPRIATION FROM THE STATE.
HAVE EXTREMELY DIFFERENT
OVERHEAD RATES FOR EXAMPLE IF IT
CAME THROUGH LA COUNTY EFFORT
CAME FROM YOLO COUNTY
[inaudible]
GOT IT [inaudible]
SO ON JANET YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE YOU HAVE SEEN IT REGIONAL
DISPARITIES IN FUNDING -- ARE
THERE STRATEGIES THAT
LEGISLATIVE BODY CAN CONSIDER --
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
WELL AS YOU KNOW A LOT OF
GOVERNMENT MONEY IS DISTRIBUTED
BASED ON POPULATION COUNTS OF
ONE SORT OR ANOTHER SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE KIND OF SURPRISED TO
SEE HOW MUCH DISPARITY THERE IS
IN GOVERNMENT FUNDING AND SO I
THINK AGAIN RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
WAY OF KNOWING.
WHAT THAT IS -- WE ARE ABLE ONLY
TO TELL GOVERNMENT FUNDING IN
TOTAL UP BY REGION WE AREN'T
ABLE TO SEPARATE IT OUT RIGHT
NOW BY FEDERAL STATE.
I'M COUNTY OR CITY SO IT'S HARD
TO KNOW RIGHT NOW WITH EXACTLY
WHAT WOULD WORK BUT I DO THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD WANT TO PAY
MORE ATTENTION -- TO JUST LIKE
YOU PAY ATTENTION TO WERE JOBS
MONEY IS GOING PAID ATTENTION TO
IS GOING IS IMPORTANT AS WELL.
I'M ONE OF THE OTHER PIECES THAT
WAS MENTIONED IS THAT -- THERE
IS A 10%.
CAP.
ON INDIRECT COSTS THAT COMES
FROM SOME OF THESE GRANTS -- IS
THAT IN SOME ACTUALLY HAVE 3% SO
HAVE EVERY SO.
IS THAT IN STATUE OR IS THAT
BASED ON THE AGENCY IS THERE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
AGENCY IF THAT FEELS.
LIKE.
FOR SOME GRANTS IT NEEDS TO
CHANGE.
IN SOME CASES IT'S WRITTEN INTO
THE LEGISLATION FOR EXAMPLE
FEDERAL MONEY MAY HAVE CAPS --
RARELY DID THE CAPS OCCUR IN
STATE FUNDING -- AND DIFFERENT
COUNTIES THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE CAN'T
SAME COUNTY WILL HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT RULES SO ONE OF THE
ISSUES FOR NON PROFITS IS THAT
THE SAME NONPROFIT LIKE THE
CENTER FUMAN SERVICES IN MODESTO
THAT I MENTIONED.
THEY MIGHT HAVE FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT INDIRECT COSTS RATES
BECAUSE THEY'RE WORKING WITH
DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
SO WE'RE DOING THE PILOT PROJECT
RIGHT NOW WITH THE AUDITOR
CONTROLLER IN LA COUNTY WITH THE
HOPES OF TRYING TO FIND A WAY SO
THAT WHEN A NON PROFITS
CONTRACTING WITH THE COUNTY.
IF THE IF THE FUNDING AGENCIES
STATE OR FEDERAL HAS NOT
SPECIFIED IN INDIRECT COSTS
RIGHT TO ALLOW THEM TO HAVE ONE
IN DIRECT COSTS RATE.
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT THIS PILOT
IN LOS ANGELES SO YOU DON'T HAVE
THE SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE HAVE
MULTIPLE INDIRECT COSTS RATES
WHICH IS CRAZY MAKING FROM AN
ADMINISTRATIVE POINT OF VIEW --
I MEAN THIS MEANS THIS MEANS
THINGS LIKE I'VE SEEN ONE FIND
ONE MEALS ON WHEELS ORGANIZATION
THAT WAS ABLE TO GET FUNDING
FROM THE GOVERNMENT FOR THE FOOD
BUT NOT FOR THE PEOPLE TO HELP
COOK IT OR FOR THE TRAYS TO PUT
THE FOOD IN.
THIS IS KIND OF THE REEDY
CRAZIES BUT LANCE TO WHICH THE
INDIRECT COSTS PRO PROBLEM CAN
SOMETIMES GO.
TO SO WE'RE HOPING THAT IF THE
PILOT IN LA GOES WELL THAT WE
MIGHT THINK ABOUT DOING IT IN
OTHER COUNTIES AT THE STATE
MIGHT CONSIDER SOMETHING LIKE
THIS TO SOME. ONE AGENCY IN THE
IF YOU HAVE ONE CONTRACT BUT SAY
WITH HUMAN SERVICES AND YOU HAVE
AN INDIRECT COST RATE WITH THEM
YOU COULD USE THAT SAME RATE FOR
YOUR CONTRACT WITH MEDIC WITH OB
FISH AND WILDLIFE WITH
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION EXETER
ABOUT WOULD BE OUR GOAL.
TENSION AND AND TELL ME A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THIS PET PROGRAM
WHEN DO YOU EXPECT TO FIND TO
FOR IT TO CONCLUDE IN WHEN YOU
MIGHT HAVE SOME.
FINDINGS OF SORTS RELATED TO
THIS SORT OF THE PILOT PROGRAM
AN ALLEY -- SO WAIT AT WHERE IS
IT IN THE STAGE VERY HARD IT IS
IT FINISH I MEAN IS A PILOT
PROGRAM GOING TO BE DONE DO WE
KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE.
IN TERMS OF THE FINDINGS OF THE
IT'S KIND OF MOVING IT IS LIKE
IT LIKE IT'S MOVING SOME
SOMETIMES IT'S LIKE AN AVALANCHE
AND MOVES INCREDIBLY FAST AND
THEN LIKE.
NOTHING HAPPENS FOR LIKE I DON'T
KNOW YOU KNOW TEN YEARS TIME SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT THE THE PILOT
WILL ACTUALLY LAUNCH THIS FALL
THIS FALL AND THEN WE'LL HAVE
RESULTS IN MAYBE SIX MONTHS TO A
YEAR.
THANK YOU GREAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ALL THREE
OF YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME.
TO TO YOU KNOW KEEP US INFORMED
A LOOK FORWARD TO STAYING IN
TOUCH -- PARTICULARLY WITH THAT
JUST THE WEBSITE OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S A BIG DEAL -- BUT ALSO OF
COURSE WITH UNDERSTANDING BETTER
AND I THINK THE FOR FOR THIS
BODY IT WE DO WANT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE FIXES COULD BE.
IF.
IF WE HAVE THE NONPROFIT SERVING
AS THE FOURTH LARGEST INDUSTRY --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE WAYS THAT YOU
COULD WORK SMOOTHER I'M ON ALL
FRONTS I A THINK IT'S NOT
INTENDED.
TO NECESSARILY JUST AT TAKE A
POSITION OF ONLY HELPING THE
NONPROFIT BUT ALSO THE STATE I
MEAN WITH THIS MUCH FUNDING
GOING TO NON PROFITS ARE THERE
ELEMENTS THAT THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY.
CONSIDER THAT WOULD FACILITATE
SOME OF THIS I KNOW IN A LOT OF
THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD AS
WELL [inaudible]
AND THE NONPROFIT WORLD AND EVEN
PAYMENT SYSTEMS ARE CHANGING
RIGHT THERE'S MORE TECHNOLOGY
INVOLVED -- AND SO A A THINK AS
WE THINK ABOUT THAT WE WOULD WE
WOULD BE AN OPEN AS A BODY TO
CONSIDER WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE.
THERE IS NOT A DEDICATED
NONPROFIT STANDING POLICY
COMMITTEE RIGHT AND SO THIS IS
OUR PLACE TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
TRANSLATE SOME OF WHAT WERE SEEN
IN OUR FOURTH LARGEST INDUSTRY
THAT SERVES MILLIONS.
OF CALIFORNIANS THAT ALSO
EMPLOYEES MANY CALIFORNIANS HOW
WE COULD FACILITATE SOME OF THAT
ELEMENT THAT COULD BE HELPFUL TO
SEEN NONPROFITS BE MORE HEALTHY
BOTH FINANCIALLY AND I THINK --
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF THEIR GOALS.
THANK YOU THANKS TO THE THREE OF
YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO BE
HERE WITH US TODAY.
NEXT -- TO OUR PANEL IS LOOKING
AT WHAT THESE PARTNERSHIPS
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE BETWEEN
NONPROFITS AND STATE AND
ENTITIES AND WE WILL START.
USING -- DISCUSSING MENTAL
HEALTH -- WE HAVE KAREN SMITH
HERE WITH THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER AND DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- WE ALSO.
I HAVE A SHINE AT USE YOU SOFT
C. AND I'M SORRY IF I MISSED --
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF OUR
MUSLIM AMERICAN SOCIETY SOCIAL.
SERVICES FOUNDATION -- AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE GUEST AND I WILL
ALLOW THAT GUESTS -- INTRODUCED
THEMSELVES THAT WE WILL GO.
GO AHEAD AND START AND THEN I
THINK WE'RE MOVING TO VETERANS
TO START.
SO -- GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A
DOCTOR KAREN SMITH I'M THE
CALIFORNIA STATE HEALTH OFFICER
THE DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PROJECTS IN OUR DEPARTMENT --
WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
HOW THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY WORKS WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
IN INNOVATIVE WAYS TO ELEVATE
COMMUNITY DEFINED -- PROMISING
PRACTICES A LITTLE BACKGROUND
FIRST ON THE PROJECT THE NAME OF
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. SEVEN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY FOUR OF TWO
THOUSAND FOUR CALIFORNIA VOTERS
PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE
NOW KNOWN AS THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT OR MHSAA.
IN MHSAA ADDRESSES AND SUPPORTS
A BROAD CONTINUATION OF
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
AND MENTAL HEALTH -- INNOVATION --
IN -- TO FOR FOR FOLKS ACROSS
THE LIFESPAN -- MHSAA ALLOCATES
20% OF THE FUNDS TO PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AS A KEY
STRATEGY TO PREVENT MENTAL
ILLNESS FROM BECOMING SEVERE AND
DISABLING.
I'M INTO A PROOF TIMELY ACCESS
FOR UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS.
THE S. P. E. I. PROGRAMS AS
THEY'RE CALLED EMPHASIZE
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES THAT MAY RESULT FROM
UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND IN RESPONSE TO THE FORMER US
SURGEON GENERAL DAVID SATCHER IS
CALL FOR NATIONAL ACTION TO
REDUCE MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES.
THE FORMER CALIFORNIA'S POINT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH CREATED A
STATEWIDE POLICY INITIATIVE TO
IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDER.
UNSERVED OR INAPPROPRIATELY
SERVED IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
FORMER DEMON DEPARTMENT
MIDDELHOFF LAUNCHED A FIRST THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE STATE WIDE
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
EFFORT CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT OR
AS I WILL REFER TO IT C. R. D.
P. -- THIS FOCUSES ON FIVE
PRIORITY POPULATIONS AFRICAN
AMERICAN ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER --
A NATIVE AMERICANS AND LESBIAN
GAY.
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER QUEER
QUESTIONING WHICH I WILL REFER
TO AS LGBT Q..
PHASE ONE OF THIS PROJECT
INVOLVED MAJOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS TO DEVELOP%
FIVE REPORTS ONE FOR EACH
SPECIAL POPULATION -- WITH
SPECIFIC STREET STRATEGIC
PLANNING WORK GROUPS WHO WERE
TASKED WITH TELLING THE STORY OF
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES WITHIN
THOSE SPECIFIC POPULATIONS.
THESE REPORTS WERE ALSO
IDENTIFIED ALSO IDENTIFIED
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
PRACTICES THAT ARE SHOWN PROMISE
IN ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH --
IN THEIR COMMUNITY A COMMUNITY
TO FIND EVIDENCE PRACTICE ARE
SET TO PRACTICES THAT
COMMUNITIES HAVE USED AND
DETERMINED BY COMMUNITY
CONSENSUS TO YIELD POSITIVE
OUTCOMES.
AND THEY MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN EMPIRICALLY SHOWN TO DO SO.
BUT THEY HAVE REACHED A LEVEL OF
ACCEPTANCE AND SUPPORT IN THE
COMMUNITY -- THAT INSURES THEIR
ON GOING NATURE AND THE
COMMUNITY BELIEVES IN THE VALUE
OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF PHASE
ONE WAS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
THIRTY TWO MEMBER CALIFORNIA
MHSAA MULTI COAT MULTI CULTURAL
COALITION.
THE COALITION BOTH SUPPORTED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE PROJECT
OVERALL -- FOR PHASE ONE BUT IT
ALSO INCLUDED A FOCUS ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OTHER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS OUTSIDE
THOSE SPECIAL POPULATIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THE MIDDLE EASTERN COMMUNITIES
AT CETERA.
THE FINAL COMPONENT OF THAT
FIRST PHASE OF THE PROJECT WAS
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE COMMUNITY
AUTHORED C. R. D. P. STRATEGIC
PLAN.
THE PLANTS THAT THE SIZE THE
FIVE POPULATION REPORTS AN
OUTLINE GOALS FOCUSED ON
CHANGING THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM TO BETTER SERVE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
C. R. D. P. FACE TWO ADDRESSES
SEVERAL OF THE GOALS FROM THE
STRATEGIC PLAN AND IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
OFFICE OFHEALTH EQUITY -- PHASE
TWO WAS LAUNCHED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND WILL SUNSET IN APRIL
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO THIS SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR INITIATIVE AIMS
TO EVALUATE AND SUPPORT
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
RESPONSIVE COMMUNITY TO FIND
EVIDENCE PRACTICES.
IMPLEMENTED BY LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
SEE OUR TO BE AIMS TO BEGIN
CREATING A CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS
OF DIVERS AND PARTICULARLY OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
IT IS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
INITIATIVE FOCUSING ON REDUCING
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
THESE FIVE PRIORITY POPULATIONS.
AND IT FOLLOWS GUIDING
PRINCIPLES OF DOING BUSINESS
DIFFERENTLY BUILDING COMMUNITY
CAPACITY FAIRNESS AND CREATING
SYSTEM CHANGE.
SUSTAINING EFFORTS TO REDUCE
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES BEYOND
THE THE SPAN OF THE CRT P. FACE
TO FUNDING REQUIRES THAT WE
INVEST IN.
CREATING OR INCREASING COMMUNITY
CAPACITY AND SOME MORE AND
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ONE OF
THE PRIMARY AIMS OF C. R. D. P.
FUNDING IS TO BRIDGE THE GAP.
BETWEEN COMMUNITY TO FIND
EVIDENCE AND THE EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES -- THAT WE GENERALLY
ACCEPT AS THE WAYS TO DO TO DO --
TO PROVIDE SERVICES I'M AND
WE'RE DOING THIS THROUGH
COMMUNITY BASED PARTS
PARTICIPATORY EVALUATION
METHODOLOGIES THAT HONOR THE
EXPERTISE TO THE COMMUNITY.
THIS APPROACH BOTH BILLS
COMMUNITY CAPACITY AND ADDS TO
THE EVIDENCE BASED FOR COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTICE.
A PROGRAM LIKE C. R. D. P. IS
DESIGNED TO DECREASE JUST
DISPARITIES.
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO BE
CHRISTOPHER SIMPLY CAN'T
PERPETUATE THOSE THAT'S WHERE
THE FAIRNESS AS A AS ONE OF THE
MAJOR PRINCIPLES THAT WE OPERATE
ENTER COMES INTO.
THE C. R. D. P. GRANTS AND
CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN AWARDED
BASED ON MERIT.
AND ONLY AFTER ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES HAVE HAD AN IN BIT HAVE
BOTH BEEN INVITED TO APPLY AND
IF NEEDED.
PROVIDED WITH THE TOOLS AND
SERVICES TO SUPPORT THEIR
APPLICATION.
SO THE CRT P. SOLICITATION
PROCESS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
HOW THIS PROP THIS PROJECT IS
DOING GIVE BUSINESS.
ESPECIALLY STATE BUSINESS
DIFFERENTLY FOR EVERY
SOLICITATION THAT WE RELEASED
PRE DRAFT SOLICITATIONS WERE
ISSUED FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THOSE COMMENTS WERE THEN
INCORPORATED INTO.
CONSIDERATIONS AS SOLICITATIONS
WERE REVISED TO BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS AND ABILITIES OF THE
APPLICANTS THEMSELVES.
THE SOLICITATION SCORING TEAMS
WERE COMPRISED OF STATE --
EMPLOYEES FROM ACROSS MULTIPLE
STATE DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
AND THERE WAS AN APPLICATION
PROCESS TO BECOME A MEMBER OF
THE STORE A SCORING TEAM AND
THIS REQUIRED EXTENSIVE PERSONAL
STATEMENTS THAT WERE EXPRESSED
BY THE ACT THAT BOTH EXPRESSED
THE APPLICANTS INTEREST IN
PARTICIPATING.
BUT ALSO DEMONSTRATED THEIR
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
COMPETENCE IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
IN WORKING WITH MULTI CULTURAL
LGBT Q. COMMUNITIES.
OF COURSE HERE TO BE DOESN'T
EXIST IN A VACUUM -- IF THE
EFFORTS TO REDUCE REDUCE
DISPARITIES THAT BEGIN WITH C.
R. T. P. -- PHASE ONE AND PHASE
TWO ARE TO BE SUSTAINED BEYOND
FUNDING WE NEED TO IMPACT THE
LARGER CONTEXT IN WHICH THESE
PROJECTS ARE ON GOING.
AND WE'RE WORKING -- TO AND TRY
TO BUILD A SMOOTHER INTEGRATION
OF THE PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
FUNDED CURRENTLY BY FACE TO
PROGRAMS INTO THE LARGER MENTAL
HEALTH COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND TO THIS AND WE'RE
WORKING TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION IN TERMS OF INCREASING
ACCESS TO CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERALL
IN THE COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS HAS BEEN NOTED IN PRETTY
MUCH EVERY REVIEW IS BEING A
REALLY A DESPERATE NEED.
SO WITH THIS YEAR TO PAY THEIR
THIRTY FIVE IMPLEMENTATION PILOT
PROJECTS -- THERE THE SOUL OF
THE THE OF THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
THESE ARE COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
BOTH IMPLEMENTING AND EVALUATING
THEIR COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE.
THAT PROVIDE CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY RESPONSIVE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES TO MEMBERS
OF THE FIVE PRIORITY POPULATIONS.
FOR MANY OF OUR THIRTY FIVE
PILOT PROJECTS THESE ARE THE
FIRST CONTACT THEY'VE EVER HAD
WITH THE STATE.
IN FACT ELEVEN OF THE THIRTY
FIVE THE CURRENT GRANTEES WERE
IN FACT FIRST GRANTED.
PILOT PROJECT TO WORDS THESE
WERE CAPACITY BUILDING AWARDS --
MET THESE THESE WERE ALL HAVE
THESE WERE ALL VERY SMALL NON
PROFITS OPERATE WITH OPERATING
BUDGETS UNDER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THEY WERE FIRST AWARDED THESE
CAPACITY BUILDING -- GRANTS
WHICH IT TOO TO RECEIVE WHICH
THEY HAD TO RESPOND TO A
SOLICITATION THAT WAS DESIGNED
TO REMOVE BARRIERS -- WITH
SEVERAL MONTHS OF OF FUNDING TO
INCREASE THEIR ABILITY -- TO
RESPOND TO THE LARGER -- THE THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROJECT
SOLICITATION SO WE HELP TO THEM --
AT CREATE ACTUALLY THE THINGS
THAT THEY NEEDED TO RESPOND TO
FOR EXAMPLE.
RELATIONS SPECIFIC TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS REFINED
THEIR DESCRIPTION OF THEIR
SPECIFIC EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE --
COMMUNITY EVIDENCE PRACTICE --
DEVELOPED A DETAILED FIVE YEAR
WORK PLAN AND BUDGET AT PROPOSED
EVALUATION PLAN AND AN
ORGANIZATIONAL GROWTH PLAN THESE
ARE ALL COMPONENTS OF THE LARGER
SOLICITATION.
I WILL SAY WE IS MEANS THESE ARE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
CONTRACTORS THAT WE THE STATE
CONTRACTED WITH TO PROVIDE THIS
OUT SO WE WEREN'T CREATING THE
SOLICITATION RESPONSES WE'RE
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF THESE
VERY SMALL ORGANIZATIONS
ACTUALLY RESPOND.
TO BASICALLY ANY KIND OF
SOLICITATION FROM THE STATE OR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- FIVE
SPECIFIC WE HAVE FIVE POPULATION
SPECIFIC TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS WHO WORK WITH THE
PILOT PROJECTS.
AND TO DEVELOP THEIR
ORGANIZATIONAL PROGRAMMATIC
EVALUATION CAPACITIES THEY ALSO
HELP THAT THE PILOT PROJECTS TO
IMPROVE THEIR OPERATIONS
IDENTIFY AND SECURE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
AND BUILD STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS
TO BETTER SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURE THEIR
SUSTAINABILITY.
WE ALSO HAVE EDUCATION OUT
REGION AWARENESS CONSULTANTS TO
HELP IMPLEMENT COMPONENTS OF THE
THIS YEAR THE P. STRATEGIC PLAN
BUT ALSO SUPPORT THE PILOT
PROJECTS IN DEMONSTRATING HOW
THEIR PROJECTS.
ARE DESIGNED TO BETTER ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF THESE UNDERSERVED.
POPULATIONS THROUGH AND THEIR
TRAINING THEM TO USE STORY
TELLING MEDIA TRAINING MEDIA
CONSULTING SERVICES PARTNERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT OUT STRATEGIES FOR
THESE NONPROFITS TO ACTUALLY
BEGIN TO BUILD FOR THEMSELVES.
PARTNERSHIPS I'M IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY HELP THEM
BE SUSTAINABLE.
AS AN OVERALL PROJECT IN AS A A
NOT PREVIOUSLY TESTED
METHODOLOGY IS ALSO BEING FULLY
EVALUATED THERE IS A STATE WIDE
EVALUATOR WHO'S KIND CONDUCTING
CROSS SITE EVALUATIONS.
THAT INCLUDE STATE ON ALL THE
COMPONENTS OF THE THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECTS
INCLUDING THE WORK THAT WE ARE
THE MEMBERS OF OUR OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY OR DOING. TWO
OBJECTIVES FOR THE OVERALL
EVALUATION ARE TO EVALUATE THE
OVERALL EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
FACE.
TO A PHASE TWO AND IDENTIFYING
AND STRENGTHENING STRATEGIES
THAT CAN REDUCE MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES WHICH IS THE
ULTIMATE OUTCOME.
AND THEN THE OTHERS TO DETERMINE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF COMMUNITY
TO FIND EVIDENCE PRACTICES IN C.
R. D. P. OVERALL THE REASON THIS --
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT IT FOR
ME IS SO IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE
THERE IS A A FIXATION AND I I
USE THAT WORD.
THOUGHTFULLY ON WHAT WE CALL
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES.
THE CHALLENGE WITH EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES IS THAT THEY
TEND TO BE A VERY EXPENSIVE
SERVE FEW PEOPLE AND REALLY HAVE
NOT BEEN VALIDATED IN ANY BUT
CERTAIN KINDS OF CONDITIONS AND
DELIVERED BY CERTAIN TYPES OF
ORGANIZATIONS CAN I ASK YOU JUST
A CLARIFYING QUESTION.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT THERE'S A
FIXATIONON EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES?
FROM YOUR LAND IS THAT A
FIXATION THAT EASE PROMPTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE BY PRACTITIONERS
BY THE GENERAL PUBLIC -- IT'S
LARGELY PROMULGATED BY FUNDERS
AND RESPONDING TO LEGITIMATE
CRITICISM THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T DO A VERY
GOOD JOB WE THAT GENERAL
COMMUNITY OF THOSE OF US WHO GOT
FINDING -- YOU KNOW DAY
DEMONSTRATING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE PROJECTS THAT WE DO DO --
WHY WE CHOOSE THIS METHODOLOGY
VERSUS I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE --
DIABETES WE DO A LOT OF WORK ON
DIABETES THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS
THAT PEOPLE APPROACH TRYING TO
GET PEOPLE TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL
IN COMMUNITIES TREATING THEIR
DIABETES.
THERE ARE ONLY ONE OR TWO THAT
HAVE BEEN RIGOROUSLY TESTED --
IT PARTICULARLY THIS IS IT THIS
WHOLE IDEA OF EVIDENCE BASEMENTS
ACTUAL CANCER MEDICINE WHERE
YOU'RE DEALING WITH ONE PERSON
ONE DOCTOR AND HOW ABOUT.
PERSONS DISEASE SHOULD BE
MANAGED -- WITH DIABETES THE ONE
THERE ARE TWO PRACTICES THAT ARE
CONSIDERED EVIDENCE BASE I
EITHER HAVE BEEN STUDIED AND
STUDIED AND STUDIED AND THEY
SEEM TO WORK.
THEY ARE THE DIABETES PREVENTION
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE WHICH HAS
VERY PRETTY AND THEY'RE ALL THE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE BECAUSE
BY THEIR VERY NATURE VERY
PRESCRIPTIVE.
AND SO -- IT TELLS THE COMMUNITY
WORKER EXACTLY HOW THEY WILL
WORK WITH THIS PATIENT WITH
DIABETES -- AS REFERRED BY THIS
DOCTOR THE CHALLENGE WITH
EXPANDING THAT TO COMMUNITIES
AND PARTICULARLY TO NON TYPICAL
COMMUNITIES.
IS THAT YOU REALLY DO HAVE TO
ADOPT YOUR SERVICES TO THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING
SERVICE.
TO AND SO WHAT THIS PROJECT DOES
IS IT SAYS WE RESPECT THE FACT
THAT COMMUNITIES BELIEVE THAT
THAT THE PRACTICE THAT'S ONGOING
AND WE CHOSE ON GOING PRACTICES
THAT THE COMMUNITIES VALUED.
HOUSE VALUE IF THE COMMUNITY
BELIEVES THAT.
THEN WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THOSE THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
DEVELOP ENOUGH EVIDENCE BY THE
WE WILL USE MORE RIGOROUS
METHODOLOGY THAN THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO USE TO EVALUATE THEIR
PRACTICES. TO THAT'S ONE GOAL IS
TO SAY WE WANT TO ADD TO THE
EVIDENCE BASE FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
AND IN PARTICULAR FOR PRACTICE
THAT WILL REDUCE MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
BASE FOR THAT AT A POPULATION
LEVEL AT ALL SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT. TO SAY YOU WILL YOU
ONLY USE EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES SO WE WANT TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT SCIENCE BY
TAKING THESE PRACTICES THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED IN COMMUNITIES.
AND RIGOROUSLY EVALUATING THEM
AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THE ONLY
ONES PROVIDING THESE INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE SERVICES.
SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY ACCESS
THE WORLD OF FUNDING.
THAT LARGELY REQUIRES THAT YOU
PROVIDE EVIDENCE THAT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING WORKS THERE CAUGHT
IN A CATCH.
TWENTY TWO THEY AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES BELIEVE THAT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WORKS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
EVALUATE IT TO THE LEVEL THAT IS
REQUIRED FOR AN EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE.
AND NO WAY TO GET THERE FROM
WHERE THEY ARE AND THEY OFTEN
DON'T HAVE THAT CAPABILITY
EITHER THAT THE ACTUAL TECHNICAL
KNOW HOW OF HOW TO DO THAT KIND
OF EVALUATION.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
BOTH SUPPORTING THESE PRACTICES
BECAUSE WE REALLY DON'T KNOW HOW
TO REDUCE DISPARITIES IN MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND FOLKS IT IN COMMUNITIES
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE A WAY TO
DO THAT THAT'S WORKING WE WANT
TO SUPPORT THAT WE WANT TO BUILD
THE EVIDENCE BASE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY WE NEED THE
NONPROFIT TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN COMMUNITIES
AND WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
BE SUSTAINABLE.
THIS IS ONE PROJECT THAT
VIOLATES ALMOST EVERY RULE OF
STATE FUNDING -- IN ORDER TO TRY
O DO THOSE THINGS SNIP WITH
PERMISSION.
THANK YOU ARE THERE AND THEY'RE
PREVENTION TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND NOW THIS
AND AND WE HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF A
REALLY OUTSTANDING NONPROFIT --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT SO HANDED.
THANK YOU DOCTOR KAREN -- THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
OPPORTUNITIES TO TALK ABOUT HOW
IS THE NONPROFIT WE'VE BENEFITED
WITH WORKING WITH THE STATE --
THE SHAPES ARE TIME -- SO -- MY
NAME IS GOES ON USE OF SITE AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE MUSLIM AMERICAN SOCIETY
SOCIAL SERVICES FOUNDATION I'M
AWFUL.
SO IN SHORT I WILL JUST REFER TO
US AS MASSIVE STUFF -- SO JUST
I'M GONNA GIVE FULLER BUT A
BACKGROUND AND THEN HOW WE
BENEFITTED AND WHERE WE HAVE
COME TO BE AS A RESULT OF BEING
FUNDED -- WITH THIS AND WITH
THIS -- VERY UNIQUE -- GRANT --
OPPORTUNITY -- SO AGAIN JUST YOU
KNOW THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME.
TIME TO BRIEFLY INFORM YOU OF
HOW MASSES STAFF AND THE
COMMUNITY WAS SERVE HAS
BENEFITED -- WITH THE OUR LONG
LONG STANDING RELATIONSHIP WITH
THIS OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY
WHICH IS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH I'M MASSIVE WAS
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN BY.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS -- SINCE THERE
WAS NO AGENCY TO PROVIDE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE SERVICES TO THE
EIGHTY AYE AYE THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
WE SERVE ALL COMMUNITIES HOWEVER
OUR EXPERTISE IS WHAT THE
LINGUIST AND CULTURES OF THESE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES -- AS YOU
ALL KNOW SACRAMENTO'S VERY
DIVERSE COMMUNITY WITH REFUGEES
AND IMMIGRANTS FROM MANY
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TRAUMA --
THERE ISAN INFLUX OF REFUGEES
IN SACRAMENTO FROM AFGHANISTAN
SYRIA AND IRAQ AND MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE DUE TO THE
INCREASE IN POPULATION ARABIC
HAS NOW BECOME ONE OF THE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I THINK WITHIN
THE LAST YEAR OR SO -- AND MATH
STUFF -- CURRENTLY HOUSE FOR
PROGRAMS ONE FACT WE'VE HAD
THESE PROGRAMS FOR A WHILE -- TO
SERVE THE COMMUNION OR TO HELP
PREVENT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
FROM BECOMING SERIOUS -- AND SO
IT'S MORE PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION WORK.
THAT WE'RE DOING -- OUR PROGRAMS
INCLUDE COUNSELING SENIOR
PROJECT COMMUNICATION AND A HAWK
LINE UP FOR YOU -- WHO ARE
FEELING THE STRESS ARE CURRENTLY
OUT OF THESE FOUR PROGRAMS ONLY
THE COUNSELING PROGRAM IS FUNDED
AT 75% -- THROUGH THE STATE
FUNDING FROM OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY THE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
RUN BY VOLUNTEERS AND COMMUNITY
DONATIONS AS MUCH AS WERE ABLE
TO GET -- THROUGH THIS FUNDING
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN AN OPPORTUNE TO
BUILD UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
OUR AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
SERVE THE COMMUNITY.
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THIS HAS BEEN IN PART FROM THE
INVESTMENT OF BEING AWARDED --
THE CAPACITY BUILDING -- AWARD
FOR SIX MONTHS -- BECAUSE WE
WERE NONPROFIT THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE NOT RECEIVED SUCH FUNDING
IT'S WE NEED AT THAT HELP FROM
THE STATE.
AND THEN AGAIN -- A FIVE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT -- THAT WAS
AWARDED A FORCE THAT FOR THIS
PROJECT THAT WE'RE DOING THE
CONSERVE PROGRAM.
I'LL BUT ALSO FROM INVESTMENT OF
MANY VOLUNTEERS IN THE TIME PUT
INTO APPLYING AND WORKING ON
THIS PROJECT -- MASSIVE HAS A
RELATIONSHIP WITH -- HE AND THE
STATE GOVERNMENT WITH
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD ON THAT --
THEIR WORK AND GIVE US A CHANCE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE EFFORTS --
WE HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
NOT BECAUSE OF THIS OPPORTUNITY
WE HAVE NOW AN UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO WORK WITH THE STATE.
GAME THROUGH THIS RELATIONSHIP
HISTORY -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT -- HE HAS CHAU AND
PATIENCE AND SUPPORT BY WORKING
WITH AN AGENCY THAT MAY NOT HAVE
THE SAME INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT MANY NONPROFITS HAVE WHEN
THEY'RE APPLYING FOR GRANTS.
I IN ADDITION OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY HAS DONE BUSINESS -- VERY
DIFFERENTLY -- OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY HAS BEEN INCLUSIVE -- UP
THE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
VERY SMALL ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
MATHIS THE SOUTH FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY AND CONTINUE TODAY
TO HAVE STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
ARE THROUGHOUT THE SOLICITATION
FOR FUNDING AND PUT WAS ALLOWED
STARTING FROM WHEN THIS ARE
STILL STATION WAS BEING
DEVELOPED -- TO WIN IT WAS
FINALIZED -- IT IS SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
COUNTIES REPLICATE -- BECAUSE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN
DONE BEFORE.
AS A RESULT NOW WE HAVE FOUR
STAFF -- I'M FULL TIME AND WE
HAVE THREE PART TIME STAFF.
WE HAVE EXPERT CONSULTANTS TO
DEVELOP OUR PROGRAMS A FINANCIAL
SYSTEM DEVELOPED POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ARE FUNCTIONING BOARD --
AND ALSO HE HAS PROVIDED US
ONGOING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IN
AREAS WHERE WE WILL LOCK OR WE
MIGHT NOT HAVE EXPERTS WITHIN
OUR GROUP -- THIS INCLUDES
TRAINING FOR STAFF TO HELP
STRAIGHTEN SKILLS ANOTHER AREA
OF NEED HUSBAND I'M REALLY
HELPING US TO DO AN ASSESSMENT
OF OUR NEEDS GROWTH AND
OPPORTUNITIES -- TO INVEST FOR
THE FOLLOWING YEAR WHICH IS
WONDERFUL EFFORT BECAUSE THEN
WERE ABLE TO ACTUALLY SEE WHAT
HAVE WE DONE AND NOW WHAT SHOULD
WE DO FOR THE NEXT YEAR --
MASSES OF HAVE HAS ALSO BEEN
ABLE TO LEVERAGE THE VISIBILITY
OF THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT.
AND THE REPUTATION OF HAVING
RECEIVED A FIVE OR STATE.
FUNDED GRANT TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
TO OTHER FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES --
IT GIVES CREDIBILITY AND
EXPERIENCE TO OUR AGENCY -- AND
HAS INCREASED -- CAPACITY AS
WELL -- WITH THAT SAID IN IT
THANK YOU FOR AGAIN FOR A FOR A
LONG SOMETIME TO TALK ABOUT HOW
WE BENEFIT AND I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
GREAT THANK YOU WE ALSO HAVE --
SO BEFORE WE CAN HAVE DO
QUESTIONS WE ALSO HAVE HERE AT
REPRESENTING OUR VETERANS
SERVICE AREAS JOSH WAS EQUALLY
MANAGER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS CHOI.
A HELL GET EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES AT TO
HELP US ALSO UNDERSTAND THIS IN
THE CONTEXT OF VETERANS SERVICES
WHICH I KNOW ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO OUR LEGISLATURE AS WELL.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR -- MY
NAME IS JOSH WAS THAT BILLION
OVERSEAS THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS IN THE BEDROOM
SERVICE DIVISION.
THANK YOU A LOT OF FOR ALLOW ME
SOMETIME TODAY TO SHARE WITH YOU
HOW ARE CURRENT OUR STRATEGY HAS
BEEN INFLUENCED BY IN WORDS
COLLABORATE WITH OUR VETERAN
WITH OUR NONPROFIT PARTNERS.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
INFLUENCE BY WERE CONDUCTED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BURKE
BUREAU AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION CREATED THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON VETERANS
OR ICV.
BY BRINGING TOGETHER MULTIPLE
BRANCHES OF BRANCHES AND LEVELS
OF FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
WHILE BEING INCLUSIVE TO
NONPROFIT SECTOR.
I SEE BE FOSTERED IT CAN AN
ECOLOGICAL APPROACH WITH THE
GOAL OF STREAMLINED DELIVERY OF
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIA SERVICE
MEMBERS VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
OVER THE YEARS THE ICV
DISCOVERED THE IMPORTANCE OF KEY
EMERGING AND EMERGING NEEDS TO
BETTER THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO
IDENTIFY FEW AN OVERALL LACK OF
COORDINATION COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
A GREATER NEED FOR READILY
ACCESSIBLE AND CULTURAL
CULTURALLY COMPETENT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE.
A NEED FOR VETERANS SPECIFIC
LEGAL SERVICES IN BOTH CRIMINAL
AND CIVIL SECTORS.
SPECIALIZED NEEDS FOR SURVIVORS
OF MILITARY SEXUAL TRAUMA
AMNESTY.
A GREAT NEED FOR PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO COMBAT THE
GROWING NUMBER OF HOMELESS
VETERANS AT THIS TIME.
THE OVERALL NEEDS AND SERVICE
GAPS IDENTIFIED THE RISE CV
PROCESS ALLOWED FOR THE
FOUNDATION FOR STRAIGHT WIDE
STRATEGIC STRATEGY FOR
CONNECTING VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. TO COMMUNITY BASED
SYSTEM CARE CORONATED AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL TO BE BUILT.
AND AND CALPERS PARTNERSHIP WITH
QUALITY NONPROFIT KERRY
REFLECTED IN EACH OF THE
PREVIOUSLY IDENTIFIED SERVICE
NEEDS TODAY. TO IMPROVE
COORDINATION COMMUNICATION
CALVET BEGAN ANNUAL SUMMIT OF
GOVERNMENTAL AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL VETERANS SERVICE
LEADERS AND STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
THE STATE.
WITH KEY REPRESENTATION FROM
CALVET EIGHT GEOGRAPHICALLY.
BASED OUT RIDLEY REGIONS THIS
EFFORT IS GEARED TOWARD THE
COORDINATION OF SERVICES AT THE
COMMITTEE LEVEL TO ENSURE.
THE CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF
RELEVANT STATEWIDE STRATEGY OF
SERVING VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
CALVET SALVAGE TEAM OPERATES
WITHIN THE EIGHT GEOGRAPHIC
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WITH
EACH REGION ASSIGNED A LOCAL
INTERAGENCY NETWORK COORDINATOR
OR LINK.
IT IS THE ROLE OF EACH OF OUR
LINKS TO NOT ONLY UNDERSTAND THE
BETTER DEMOGRAPHIC OF THE REGION
BUT ALSO TO BE FLUENT IN
EXISTING VETERAN SERVICE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEIR SON
REGION'S.
AND WORK DIRECTLY WITH
GOVERNMENTAL AND QUALITY
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS.
BOTH INCLUSIVE AND EXCLUSIVE OF
LEADERSHIP SUMMIT TO ENSURE A
QUICK AN ACTOR REFERRALS FOR
VETERANS IN NEED.
THE LINK PROBLEM PROGRAM ALSO
SERVES.
AS THE OUTRAGE FOR HOW RICH UP
FOR VETERANS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS ALIKE.
WHILE ENSURING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S OVERALL STRATEGY IN
THE REGION.
WITHIN CALVET AVERAGE BRANCH OR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE ACT.
PROGRAM ALSO WORKS INCLUDE IN
COORDINATION WITH THE DELIVERY
OF CULTURALLY COMPETENT MENTAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE WITH
OUR COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICE CBS THOSE.
PARTNERS.
AND VARIOUS NONPROFIT STATEWIDE.
AS YOU KNOW RECENT RECENT.
RESEARCH FROM SORTS OF PLASTERS
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCES OFFICE.
HAVE SHOWN THE DIRECT NEED FOR
MORE VETERAN SPECIFIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE OPERATING ON CAMPUS.
WITH ONE REPORT SHOWING 32% OF
STUDENT VETERANS INDICATING THEY
HAVE KNOWN OF ANOTHER STUDENT.
THAT HAS HAD SUICIDAL THOUGHTS
AND 22% INDICATING THE NOVELL
STUDENT HAS ATTEMPTED SUICIDE.
WITH NEARLY SIXTY THOUSAND
STUDENT VETERANS IN A COMMUNITY
CALLED SYSTEM.
THESE FINISH THESE FIGURES
INDICATING HUGE NEED.
A VETERAN SPECIFIC BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CARE FOR STUDENT THAT'S
IN RESPONSE CALVET IN
COORDINATION WITH THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES.
AND THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT US
VETS WILL BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN
EXPAND AVAILABILITY.
OF LICENSED OR SUPERVISED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS TO MORE
THAN.
NINETEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ACROSS LOS ANGELES.
SEVEN THROUGH SEVEN ROUGHLY NINE
THOUSAND STUDENT VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WOULD DROP IN
ANONYMOUS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
AT NO COST TO THE VETERAN OR
CAMPUS. TO FILL GAPS WITHIN THE
LEGAL SERVICES ARENA CVS THOSE
IN ORANGE COUNTY SAN BERNARDINO.
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTIES IN
COORDINATION WITH CALVET I'LL
REACH OUR HOST A MONTHLY FREE
LEGAL CLINICS TO THE NONPROFIT
BETTER LEGAL INSTITUTE VIELE.
THE FOCUS OF THESE CLINICS IS TO
PROVIDE THE HOMELESS AND OR LOW
INCOME CLIENTS WHOSE ACCESS TO
OR MAINTENANCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT REQUIRES DIRECT
INTERVENTION OF LEGAL AID.
WITH THESE CLIENTS.
WHICH THESE CLIENTS COULD NOT
OTHERWISE AFFORD.
THESE LEGAL CLINICS AIM TO
PROVIDE OUR REACH FOR VULNERABLE
TRANSITIONING SERVICE MEMBERS
VETERANS THEIR FAMILIES TO
REMOVE LEGAL BARRIERS.
PREVENTING ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CARE.
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CALVET IN
COORDINATION WITH CINEMA COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICE.
IS WORKING WITH THE NONPROFIT
READY TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
THE SURVIVORS OF MST THROUGH ITS
FORGOTTEN WARS PROJECT.
READY IS THE COUNTY SOUL RAPE
CRISIS TRAUMA AND HEALING CENTER
AND THE ONLY.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SEXUAL ASSAULT
CRISIS LINE CINEMA COUNTY. TO
SERVE BOTH MALE AND FEMALE
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ANY PROVIDES CRISIS INTERVENTION
PREVENTION EDUCATION ADVOCACY
AND COUNSELING.
AND AN ALTERNATE HEARING GROUPS
BY CALIFORNIA STATE CERTIFIED
RAPE CRISIS COUNSELORS AND OTHER
LICENSE CONDITIONS. TO COMBAT
VETERAN HOMELESSNESS IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN VOTERS
APPROVED PROPOSITION FORTY ONE
WHICH PROVIDED SIX HUNDRED
MILLION TO FUND VETERANS HOUSING.
AND HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
PROGRAM.
THE H. H. P..
WHICH ALLOCATED FUNDS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO ARE HOMELESS OR AT
RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
PARTNER WITH VETERANS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DWELLINGS IN INCLUDING
SUPPORTER.
THOUSAND WHICH WILL PROVIDE
HOUSING AND SERVICES TO VETERANS.
WHO ARE HOMELESS OR?
WHO HAVE EXTREMELY LOW INCOME TO
ASSIST THE VETERANS TO ACHIEVE
HOUSING STABILITY AND APPROVED
SELF SUFFICIENCY?
THE VIEWS H. B. PROGRAM
REPRESENTS A COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS AND THE STATE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS CHRONIC
SOCIAL PROBLEMS EXPERIENCED BY.
THE THOUGHTS OF BETTER
POPULATION.
AS MR HELD ITS ORGANIZATION IS
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN APARTMENT OF
THE IT IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SERVICE WHICH COMMUNITIES.
I WILL LET HIM SHARE WITH YOU
THIS PARTNERSHIP.
ACROSS ALL EXAMPLES PROVIDED THE
KEY TAKEAWAY HERE IS TWO FOLD.
FIRST IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST QUALITY OF SERVICES TO
VETERANS.
THAT COME IN CONTACT WITH
APARTMENT THERE MANY TIMES AT
WHICH A QUALITY NONPROFIT ENTITY
IS BEST ABLE TO FILL.
THE NEED DUE TO THE FLEXIBILITY
IN THE PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY.
OR NEEDS THAT REQUIRE
SPECIALIZED SERVICE AND SECOND
THAT OUR NONPROFIT PARTNERS ACT
AS A FORCE MULTIPLIER IN IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF BROADER
STRAIGHT WIDE.
STRATEGIES TO IMPROVE COMMUNITY
BASED SYSTEM OF CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA SERVICE MEMBERS
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR CHECK CALVET
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
FOR THIS INVITATION -- HOPE TO
IDEA OF A LITTLE QUICK SLIDE
SHOW FOR YOU -- TODAY I'LL BE
TALKING A BIT ABOUT YOUR
BACKGROUND FOR KILLED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION VETERANS
SERVICE AGENCIES DISCUSS OUR
RELATIONSHIPS.
WITH STATE LOCAL AGENCIES -- AND
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF CABS AS
POLICY PRIORITIES HIGHLIGHTS
SEVERAL OF OUR RECENT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND AND OUTLINED
SOME OF OUR FUTURE STRATEGIES
FOR COORDINATION WITH STATE
AGENCIES AND THE LEGISLATURE ON
VETERANS RELATED PUBLIC POLICY --
CANCER FORMED A BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE I DON'T KNOW WHERE
IN THIS OF THE SCALE.
AND THE DEPTH OF THE CHRONIC
PROBLEMS FACING OUR VIETNAM
VETERANS -- INCLUDING A LACK OF
ACCEPTANCE BACK INTO CIVILIAN
LIFE AFTER A WASTED WAR -- AGAIN
WE ORGANIZED IN -- NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WE'RE NOW
CONSORTIUM OF SEVEN COMMUNITY
BASED VETERANS SERVICE.
NONPROFIT AGENCIES COVERING
CALIFORNIA FROM EUREKA SAN DIEGO --
THESE ARE THE SEVEN AGENCIES
VERY QUICKLY -- U. S. THAT'S IS
A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION -- BUT
IN CALIFORNIA THEY'RE LOCATED IN
ORDER LA LEARN ORANGE COUNTY
VENTURE AND RIVERSIDE.
THE VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS
ARE LOCATED MONTEREY NORTH TO
EUREKA -- THE VETERANS VILLAGE
OF SAN DIEGO IS THE LARGEST --
VETERANS SERVICE PROVIDER IN SAN
DIEGO.
NEW DIRECTIONS IS IN LOS ANGELES
OR JUST IS IN OAKLAND AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND THE CALIFORNIA VETERANS
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IS IN IN
BAKERSFIELD -- AND THE VETERANS
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
WORKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OUR MISSION STATEMENT -- CABS IS
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT
VETERANS OF ALL.
ERAS HAVE THE UNDERSTANDING
TOOLS AND SUPPORT FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES REVISED FOR
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION BACK HOME.
AND WE ADVOCATE FOR REFORM AT
THE STATE LOCAL AND NATIONAL
LEVEL TO INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR ALL
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
FACTORS AND EVENTS THAT
MOTIVATED CABS IS FORMATION
INCLUDED INITIALLY A VERY
ERRATIC -- WORK FORCE
IMPROVEMENT -- PROGRAM THAT WAS
FOR STATE FUNDING -- FOR FOR
WORK FORCE -- DEVELOPMENT FOR
VETERANS -- WE FOUND THE PROGRAM
TO THE ERRATIC IN VERY DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND -- PROGRAM FUNDING --
WAS THERE ONE YEAR AND NOT THERE
THE NEXT AND IT'S VERY HARD TO
KEEP PROGRAMS GOING -- UNDER
THAT WE ALSO FOUND THAT THERE
WAS A LACK OF A CULTURAL
COMPETENCE COMPETENCY.
IN THE IN IN IN MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
PROVERBIAL PROVIDED AT THAT
POINT FOR THE VETERANS -- ALSO.
WE SAW GROUP A GROWING NEED TO
FILL THE GAP LEFT BY VETERANS
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS WHO
FOCUSED ALMOST ENTIRELY ON
BENEFITS AND EMPLOYMENT.
BUT NOT ON SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
HOMELESS VETERANS -- AND AND
VETERAN CENTRIC SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND THOSE ISSUES OF ALWAYS BEEN
A CORE OF OF THAT OF OF CANCERS --
POLICY PROGRAM -- SO WE SET
ASIDE REGIONAL DIFFERENCES SEVEN
AGENCIES -- OFTEN COMPETED FOR
SOMETIMES FOR FOR GRANTS WE SET
THOSE DIFFERENCES ASIDE AND
ORGANIZED.
IN ORDER TO BECOME A MORE
ENGAGED AND MORE ENGAGE IN STATE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS.
AND WE FOCUSED ON A COMMON
AGENDA OF IMPROVING SERVICES FOR
VETERANS IN GENERAL [inaudible]
AT TYPICAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WE ARE TYPICAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WITH
BOARD MEMBERS BEING THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE MEMBER
AGENCIES ALL.
OF MEMBERS OF OF OF THE BOARD
OUR VETERANS -- ARE KEY FOCUSES
BEEN STATE AND FEDERAL HAVE IT'S
ADVOCACY -- OF SINCE THE VAST
AMOUNT OF OUR REVENUES ARISE
FROM FEDERAL GRANTS INCLUDING --
SUCH GRANTS IS -- THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS SUPPORT HOUSING VASH
GRANTS FOR HOUSING AND
SUPPORTERS SERVICES.
GRAND PER DIEM PROGRAM THAT'S
FUNDED OUT OF FEDERAL VA.
OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH STATE
AGENCIES INCLUDES POLICY --
COORDINATION PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
LEGISLATION AND FUNDING -- AND
AND AGAIN I THINK ONE OF THE THE
KEYS AND ALL DISCUSSES A LITTLE
BIT LATER IS THAT WERE SORT OF
THE FRONT LINE PRINT SERVICE
PROVIDERS VETERANS WE UNDERSTAND
DAY TO DAY.
THE THE NEEDS IN THE AND THE
ISSUES THAT ARE CONFRONTED BY
THEM.
AND AND I THINK MOST EFFECTIVELY
WHEN WE PROVIDE THAT CONDUIT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE BACK TO
THE STATE AGENCIES AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEM.
IT'S MUCH MUCH EASIER TO TARGET
STATE RESOURCES FEDERAL
RESOURCES.
NONPROFIT RESOURCES ON ON THOSE
NEEDS AND ISSUES.
THESE ARE POLICY PRODUCE BY A BY
ISSUE AREAS SO WE'VE WE'VE COME
TO FOCUS ON LARGELY A MENTAL
HEALTH AND AND WELLNESS.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT
VETERAN TREATMENT COURTS YOU'LL
SEE IS ENGAGED IN THOSE -- IN
AND WHAT AND LEGISLATION THOSE
AREAS AND WITH THE VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES WORKING THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING.
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IT JUST
PROGRAMS AND FUNDING FOR
VETERANS.
UNDER HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING --
PROPOSITION FORTY ONE AS WAS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BY THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER -- CALVET HOME
LOANS NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM.
DISCRIMINATION IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNDER TRAINING AND
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT -- LACK OF
EMPLOYMENT SERVICE DOLLARS.
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
GERBIL A GERBIL ABUSES --
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING ISSUES CERTIFICATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
STATE FUNDING AND MEDICARE --
WE'RE TRYING TO BREAK THE CODE
AND MEDICARE BECAUSE WE STRUGGLE
FINDING SUPPORT SERVICES FUNDING
PARTICULARLY WITH CUTS MANY MANY
VERY GOOD HOW HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
NOW.
BUT WE CAN PUT PEOPLE IN THE
HOUSING.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE MONEY FOR
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IT IS ONLY
HALF HALF OF THE PROBLEM IS
SOLVED.
SOME FOR CRITICAL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS -- LEADERSHIP IN
DEVELOPING THAT THE TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND TEN STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR VETERANS -- WE'VE WE'VE
WORKED VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH
WITH CALVET AND WITH -- H. CD ON
THE VETERANS HOME A HOUSING AND
HOMES PREVENTION PROGRAM -- BOND
PROGRAM PROPOSITION FORTY ONE
WHICH PROVIDED SIX HUNDRED
MILLION. FOR CONSTRUCTION AND
AND VETERANS PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING -- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GATHER A GARNER FIFTY
SIX MILLION ROUGHLY FIFTY SIX
MILLION AND HOUSING LOANS.
AND THE INS AND RIGHT NOW THAT
PROGRAMS SUPPORTING OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM A LOT WHEN WE
SEE THE CURRENT HOUSING.
STATISTICS AND AND THE GROWTH
THAT WE SEE IN A HOMELESSNESS
BUT THIS PROGRAM IS MAKING A
DENT FOR VETERANS IN A BIG WAY.
AND AND THE AND THE PITCH FOR A
SOME LEGISLATION TO HOPEFULLY
EXPAND THAT PROGRAM OR CONTINUE
THAT PROGRAM I THINK WE'VE USED.
ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF THE
OF THOSE DOLLARS.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN REFUND THAT
PROGRAM AGAIN BECAUSE IT HAS
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE -- WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE WITH THE
MHS ALWAYS SEE -- ON A LOOK AND
AND AND AND LOCAL FUNDING -- FOR
FOR VETERANS MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS TRYING TO OBTAIN MORE
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE MONEY AT
A LOCAL LEVEL FOR VETERANS -- WE
SERVED ON THE TO THE THE THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
PROPOSITION ONE AND TWO WHICH
AGAIN PROVIDED VICE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS -- FOR FOR CALVIN HOME
LOAN PROGRAM AND TWO BILLION --
FOR THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM LINKING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITH HOUSING.
AND THAT WE SPONSOR VARIETY
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR A COUPLE
OF BILLS -- WE SPONSOR WERE VERY
ACTIVE THIS YEAR ON LEGISLATION --
POINT ABOUT WHAT CABS TO
GENERATE FOR THE STATE -- WE'VE
GOT MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA.
A MORE THAN TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND VETERANS ARE SERVED
EACH YEAR -- MORE THAN FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE BROUGHT INTO THE STATE
THROUGH THE CAVS AGENCIES.
AND MORE THAN FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN IS SPENT IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY WAS SPENT
IN CALIFORNIA.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT FIFTY FIVE
MILLION THAT THE DIFFERENCE
THERE IS PROBABLY ABOUT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE CAN
GENERATE IN -- IN IN IN.
IN IN PROVIDING GRANTS AND LOANS
FROM -- THE AT THE VARIOUS OTHER
NON PROFITS AND CORPORATE
FUNDING AND THAT TYPE OF THING --
AND THIS IS IMPACT DATA BY -- BY
AGENCIES ALSO I'LL SCAN THROUGH
THAT VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE I JUST
GAVE YOU THE SUMMARY DATA -- BUT
EACH OF THESE AGENCIES -- HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF AN
EMPLOYMENT BASED ON THEIR
VARIOUS AREAS AND PROVIDE AND
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS -- IT AND BRING
IT INTO CALIFORNIA FOR SERVING
OUR VETERANS.
SO OUR FUTURE STRATEGIES AND
INVOLVING NEEDS -- WE'RE LOOKING
AT AGAIN THE INVOLVING NEEDS
AFFECTED SERVICES WE WERE
STARTED AS A AS AN ORGANIZATION
SERVING VIETNAM VETERANS COMING
HOME FROM THE VERY UNPOPULAR WAR --
BUT WE'RE NOW SERVING POST NINE
ELEVEN VETERANS -- UNFORTUNATELY --
ENCOUNTERING SIGNIFICANT%
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES MANY COMING
BACK FROM EXTENDED TOURS OF DUTY
IN IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN AND
OTHER.
OTHER COUNTRIES SOME WERE ISSUES
THAT WERE ALSO FOLK NOT FOCUSING
ON BACK TO THE VIETNAM VETERANS
ISSUE ARE VIRGINS POPULATION IS
AGING.
AND WITH THOSE AGING VETERANS
BECOME COME THE TYPICAL PROBLEMS
THAT YOU SEE FROM PHYSICAL AND
AND AND MEDICAL CARE ISSUES AT
THAT OCCUR WITH AGING -- WE
FOCUS ON THAT -- WOMEN'S
VETERANS ISSUES A POST NINE
ELEVEN VETERANS ISSUES THAT WE
TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH --
SERVICES AND FUNDING IS STILL
AND CONTINUES TO BE A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR US VETERANS HOUSING
AND RE AUTHORIZATION PROP.
FORTY ONE AFTER CARE CASE
MANAGEMENT FOR VETERANS AND
PERMANENT HOUSING MEDICAL
BILLING AND CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT
AND EMPLOYMENT FUNDING.
I THINK THE ONE THOUGHT THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE -- WITH WITH
THE COMMITTEE IS THAT ARE
ENGAGING WITH STATE AGENCIES AND
NON PROFITS CAN BE I THINK AN
INVALUABLE ASSET FOR STATE
AGENCIES -- AND FOR NON PROFITS
AS WELL BECAUSE WE WE DIRECTLY
SERVE AFTER IS IN NEED AND WE
CAN PROVIDE A DIRECT VOICE -- TO
THOSE AGENCIES AND FOR THOSE
AGENCIES TO THE VETERANS FOR
INTO VETERANS.
WE CAN SERVICE A REAL TIME VOICE
FOR DEVELOPING PROGRAMS AND
ALLOCATING RESOURCES EFFECTIVELY.
AND WHILE THE AGENCIES CAN
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED EXPERTISE
AND IDENTIFYING RESOURCE AND
PROGRAMS THAT CAN HELP VETERANS
IN NEED -- IN NEED OF SUPPORT.
WE'VE DONE I THINK A GOOD JOB
OVER THE YEARS OF WORKING WITH
CAL THAT.
AND THE IMAGE AS ALWAYS SHE HAD
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THESE IN
VARIOUS ISSUES -- AGAIN
NONPROFITS CAN PROVIDE A DIRECT
LINK TO VETERANS IN NEED AND WE
DEPEND ON THESE THAT ARE
AGENCIES IN MANY CASES FOR
PROGRAMS SUPPORT AND FUNDING.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION ONE GENERAL
QUESTION FOR EACH OF YOU TO
THINK ABOUT IS IN YOUR
PRESENTATION.
YOU ALL DESCRIBED -- ELEMENTS
THAT WORKED ON BETWEEN THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE FUNDING
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S MOSTLY
GOVERNMENT IS THE FUNDING --
FROM THE FUNDING THE NON PROFITS
AND THE SERVICE PROVIDERS BUT
YOU ALL ALLUDED. TO ADD MORE
COULD BE DONE OR YOU'VE SAID
THIS IN IN DIFFERENT WAYS FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE -- WHAT MORE
COULD BE DONE BY GOVERNMENT
BESIDES INCREASE FUNDING BECAUSE
THEY THINK THAT THAT?
A DIFFERENT CHALLENGE BUT EIGHT
IN TERMS OF MAKING THESE
PARTNERSHIPS WORK SMOOTHER WHAT
ELSE CAN GOVERNMENT DO.
AND I IN SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA
DO TO MAKE THIS.
DIFFERENT I MEAN IN IN IN IN
YOURCASE WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH IS IT REDEFINING
THING IS IT RECONSIDERING THINGS.
I THINK NOT JUST FOR MENTAL
HEALTH BUT ACROSS THE BOARD --
TO I'LL STICK WITH THE TOPIC
EVERITT WHICH IS.
OUR FUNDING -- DISCOVERED
APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING
OVER 80% OF THE FUNDING THAT WE
HAVE THAT TOO EFFECT PROGRAMS IS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT
COMES WITH INCREDIBLY.
STRICT TIME LIMITS EVERYTHING'S
IN SILOS.
AND PEOPLE AND THE SERVICES THAT
PEOPLE NEED ARE NOT SILENCE.
AND SAID THERE'S A THERE'S A
REAL TENSION THERE AND THAT IS
ESPECIALLY AN ISSUE WHEN YOU'RE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
ESPECIALLY SMALL NONPROFIT I WAS
BEEN ON SEVERAL BOARDS.
I USED TO BE I WORKED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL FOR TEN YEARS WELL
EIGHTEEN YEARS -- THEY THEIR
SERVICES ARE DESIGNED TO SERVE
THE HUMANS NOT A PARTICULAR
DISEASE PROCESS OR WHETHER IT'S
MENTAL HEALTH OR WHATEVER AND SO
THEY HAVE GREATER FLEXIBILITY.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT BECAUSE MOST OF THE MONEY
THAT WE SEND DOWN IS FEDERAL
WE'RE LIMITED TO WHAT CONGRESS
HAS SAID THIS PARTICULAR FUNDING
STREAM CAN BE USED -- FOR WITH
STATE MONEY THE ABILITY -- TO TO
HAVE THE LEGISLATURE NOT IT'S
NOT THROUGH THE DOORS OPEN INTO
WITH THIS MANY ANYTHING YOU WANT
BUT TO ALLOW FOR FLOOD A LITTLE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE ABSOLUTE
EITHER THE TARGET POPULATION OR
THE ACTIVITIES -- TO ALLOW FOR
DISCRETION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BECAUSE EACH COMMUNITY IS
DIFFERENT EACH OF THE
POPULATIONS WE SERVE ARE
DIFFERENT.
AND SO AND ALSO IF YOU IF YOU
ONLY EVER DO THE SAME THING YOU
WILL NEVER INNOVATE ANYTHING AND
SO THERE'S NOT.
I THINK THE OTHER THING IS --
THERE ARE AS WAS MENTIONED BY
THE EARLIER PANEL THE
RESTRICTION ON OVERHEAD.
CAN BE REALLY PROBLEMATIC WE
HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM BOTH WITH
THE MONEY THAT COMES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO FROM
SOME OF THE STATE MANY FOR US TO
AFFECT PROGRAMS WE KNOW JUST HOW
HARD IT IS TO DO WHEN WE GET.
ABOUT HALF OF WHAT IT ACTUALLY
COSTS.
IT'S THAT MUCH MORE DAMAGING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT THE
ABILITY TO ALLOW US TO SET
REALISTIC IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR MONEY
GOES OUT TO LOCALS AND FOR EACH
COUNTY -- WE HAVE BECAUSE WE
HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT FUNDING
STREAMS RETURN TWENTY ONE
PROGRAM SO THAT WE HAVE MULTIPLE
CONTRACTS WITH EVERY COUNTY.
WE CAME UP WITH THE PROCESS
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO TO SET A
STANDARD -- OVERHEAD RATE FOR
EACH COUNTY THEY'RE NOT ALL THE
SAME BECAUSE EACH COUNTIES
DIFFERENT.
BUT THAT WAY ALL OF OUR GRANTS
THEY KNOW EXACTLY HOW MUCH
OVERHEAD THEY'LL GET AND IT'S
DESIGNED TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
MEET THEIR NEEDS SOME KIND OF
SIMILAR PROCESS FOR AGENCIES.
CAN HELP IT.
NOT FOR EVERY AGENCY BECAUSE
SOME OF THE AGAIN SOME OF THE
FINDINGS RESTRICTED BY THE FEDS
BUT TO WHEN WE CAN WITH STATE
MONEY TO ALLOW US TO WORK MORE
CLOSELY WITH THE FLEXIBILITY.
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
LOCAL NONPROFITS NEED TO
ACTUALLY BE SUCCESSFUL I THINK
THAT WOULD BE THE ONE THING THAT
COULD REALLY HELP THANK YOU.
AT THAT ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I
THINK IS AN I. I'LL SPEAK -- NOW
I'M NOT NECESSARILY FROM -- A
CANCER PERSPECTIVE BUT FROM A
GENERAL NONPROFIT PERSPECTIVE
WHAT I'VE SEEN IN WORKING WITH
OTHER NON PROFITS PARTICULAR IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH GRANT SIDE.
AND THAT IS SAID -- NONPROFITS
TEND NOT TO BE ALL THAT
SOPHISTICATED I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE RECOGNIZE
FAIRLY EARLY ON AND I THINK
GENERALLY SPEAKING CAPS AS AS
DEVELOPED OVER THE YEARS WE'VE
BEEN AROUND FOR AWHILE -- Và
SOPHISTICATED APPROACH TO PUBLIC
POLICY IN A AND AN UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO -- TO
OBTAIN GRANT MONEY MOST
NONPROFITS.
ARE THAT SOPHISTICATED AND AND
THE GRANT PROCESS OFTEN TIMES
THAT WE'VE SEEN CAN BE
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLICATED AN
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE TO GET
ENGAGED IN -- AUNTS AND SO YOU
HAD TO TYPICALLY IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE APPLYING FOR GRAD SOME
PLACE -- IF YOU FOR NONPROFITS
WRITING THAT GRANT THEMSELVES
IT'S PROBABLY COULD BE WRITTEN
VERY WELL -- SO YOU'RE LOOKING
AT HIGHER GRANT WRITERS SO THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU HAVE TO
EXPAND ACCESS THAT MONEY.
CAN BE CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT AT
TIMES -- FROM A STRICTLY FROM A
CABS A PERSPECTIVE -- ALL AND
AND AND AND THIS IS MORE FROM
PUBLIC POLICY ILL MOST OF OUR
MONEY COMES FROM FEDERAL GRANTS
I MENTIONED EARLIER.
AND IT'S IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE. TO TO COORDINATE --
EIGHTY COHESIVE AND CONCISE
MESSAGE BACK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON ON FUNDING ISSUES
AND I KNOW OUR OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT
ALWAYS THE BEST -- OFTENTIMES A
VECTOR TO VETERANS ISSUES WERE
FORTUNATE AND IN THE MESSAGES
CAN BE.
DELIVERED PRETTY EFFECTIVELY BUT
WORKING WITH THE THE NONPROFIT
SAID THAT ACTUALLY ARE ACTIVE
BACK IN IN DC AND AND WE WORK OF
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE WITH --
FREQUENTLY -- IN FACT GEORGE
WHILE HE IS A GREAT RESOURCE FOR
US -- TO TO TO HELP FILTERS
POLICIES SO WHEN PEOPLE ARE
GOING BACK TO DC WE EXCHANGE
MESSAGES ON ON ON WHAT WHAT'S A
PRIORITY -- BUT I THINK WE COULD
DO A MUCH MUCH BETTER JOB OF
THAT AS WELL -- IN IN JUST
COORDINATING OUR OUR MESSAGES
BACK TO DC [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- CAN YOU RESTATE
ACOSTA JUST QUICKLY SO JUST FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT CAN
GOVERNMENT DO TO FACILITATE.
THE WORK THAT YOU DO BESIDES
INCREASE SPENDING SURE.
OKAY SO I HAVE TWO THINGS THAT I
THINK OF SPEAKING ON FROM --
NONPROFIT THAT -- PROVIDE
SERVICES TO AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES -- I THINK THERE'S
TWO THINGS THAT COULD COULD HELP --
ONE IS JUST AND HAD A REAL --
NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO BE ABLE TO
ASK THE COMMUNITY WHAT ARE YOU
NEEDS WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS WHEN THEY
COME TO REFUGEES ARE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES -- BUT YOU KNOW
THERE'S OTHER NEEDS THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THE WELLNESS OVERALL.
FOR A PARTICULAR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNICATING DOING AN EXTENSIVE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT -- FOR LACK OF
BETTER WORD WOULD BE ONE I THINK
THAT WOULD BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL --
ANOTHER THING IS ADVOCACY
ENABLING UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
TO BE ABLE TO KNOW WHAT IS
ADVOCACY AND WHAT ARE THE
BENEFITS MANY -- COMMUNITIES --
OR EVEN NON PROFITS -- ARE NOT
OUR SMALL NONPROFIT SPECIALLY --
ARE NOT TRAINED OR DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH EXPERIENCE AND ADVOCACY
AND I THINK THAT'S A HUGE PART
OF MAKING A GUY YOU KNOW.
HELPING THE COMMUNITY OVERALL.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT
BECAUSE IT ECHOES I THINK WHAT
THE OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IN THIS.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HAS TOUCHED
ON THE FACT THAT [inaudible]
MOST -- NON PROFITS AREN'T
COMFORTABLE OR CLEAR WHERE
ADVOCACY IS ALLOWED IN IS NOT
ALLOWED AND SO -- GREATER
AWARENESS CONTINUES TO BE AN
ISSUE FOR THE TWO YEARS I KNOW
WE'VE TRIED TO TACKLE THAT SO I
APPRECIATE.
HEARING THAT FROM YOU.
SO THE THE CALIFORNIA TERMS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS STILL THEM
IN ITS INFANT STAGES WERE ABOUT
TWO YEARS SO WE'RE CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING -- AND I THINK -- ARE
THE MAIN KEY FOR US IS TO TO BE
ABLE TO SAYS VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES SERVICE MEMBERS THROUGH
THEIR ENTIRE LIFE SO THEIR THEIR
NEEDS ARE GOING TO CHANGE I
THINK WITH COLLABORATION WITH
QUALITY NON PROFITS THAT WERE.
WERE WERE CUT WERE INVOLVED WITH
NOW -- WERE ABLE TO MISTER HOGAN
MENTION A LOT OF A LOT OF STUFF
IS.
SOLELY BAKER BASED ON EMPLOYMENT
EDUCATION BUT TO ADD SOME
SUPPORT SERVICES IS WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW -- WITH US BETS TOWARD
THE PLOW SHARES WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND INVOLVED
WE HAVE.
AS I MENTIONED THE NINETEEN
CAMPUSES IN LOS ANGELES THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE SUPPORT
SERVICES THERE HOPEFULLY THAT'S
ABLE TO EXPAND OVER THE THE NEXT
FEW YEARS THAT WOULD BE IDEAL TO
HAVE SOME.
SOMEONE ON SOME CAMPUS WHERE
VETERANS SERVICE MEMBER THEIR
FAMILY CAN SPEAK TO ABOUT ANY
ANY ISSUES THAT.
MAYBE THE SCHOOL DOESN'T HAVE SO
WE WANT TO PROVIDE THAT AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- BASICALLY
ANYWHERE WHERE THERE'S A A LARGE
GROUP OF VETERANS THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE IN THAT.
AS YOU ALL THINK ABOUT THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND THE
PARTNERSHIPS YOU HAVE WITH OTHER
NON PROFITS OTHER COMMUNITY
AGENCIES WITH SCHOOL SITES WITH
COMMUNITIES -- ALTOGETHER.
ARE THERE ELEMENTS THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT COULD BE HELPFUL
PARTICULARLY FOR SMALLER
NONPROFITS THERE'S THIS IDEA
THAT IF YOU'RE LARGER NONPROFIT
YOU MIGHT BE MORE SOPHISTICATED
YOU HAVE GREATER CAPACITY -- BUT
IN CALIFORNIA SO MANY OF THE
NONPROFIT SAD THAT MAKE UP THIS
FOURTH LARGEST INDUSTRY ARE
STILL CONSIDERED YOU KNOW
SMALLER MEDIUM SIZE FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ARE THERE ELEMENTS
THAT.
CAN ENHANCE A SUCCESSFUL
PARTNERSHIP -- IS IT ADVANCE
PAYMENTS IT SOUNDS LIKE
FLEXIBILITY FEEL LIKE THIS IS A
THEME THAT I'M HEARING --
FLEXIBILITY IT IS PART OF IT BUT
IS IT MULTI YEAR FUNDING VERSUS
SINGLE YOUR FUNDING -- PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHAT WHAT
KINDS OF THINGS DO YOU THINK CAN
HELP -- SO SMALLER NONPROFITS
GET TO THIS.
LEVEL THAT'S ONE OF THE PIECES
OF THE THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT THAT WE ARE
MOST PROUD OF IS THAT WE HAD
THESE CAPACITY BUILDING GRANTS
AND THEY WERE SPECIFIC THEY
WEREN'T AROUND BUILDING YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH CAPACITY.
THERE ARE AROUND HOW DO YOU
APPLY FOR A GRANT WHAT DOES YOUR
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE NEED TO
LOOK LIKE SO THAT YOU KNOW HOW
TO INVOICE THAT SO THAT YOU KNOW
HOW.
TO DEMONSTRATE WHAT YOU'VE DONE
WITH THE MONEY BUT THEN THE
OTHER PIECE AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR SMALL
NONPROFITS WHO ARE SORT OF
MISSION FOCUSED IS.
HOW DO YOU TELL YOUR STORY?
AND HOW DO YOU SEE HOW DO YOU
LOOK AT YOUR COMMUNITY AND
FIGURE OUT WHO ARE THE STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS AND THEN HOW DO YOU
APPROACH THOSE PEOPLE IN ORDER
TO BUILD.
PARTNERSHIPS FOR YOUR NOT MOST
NONPROFITS DO WELL WHEN THEY'RE
LINKED IN WITH OTHER NON PROFITS
AS YOU ARE MAKING REALLY AN
ELEGANT CASE -- FOR AND IT HELPS
IF THEY'RE THAT THAT HELPS THEM
IN ADVOCACY AS WELL AND SO I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A PACKAGE OF
THINGS THAT.
HELP YOU BOTH.
ADMINISTRATIVELY IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT WE WE'RE AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS -- WE
HAVE CHALLENGES IN BEING.
TIMELY WITH PAYMENTS BUT
NONPROFITS OFTEN HAVE CHALLENGES
EVEN KNOWING HOW TO INVOICE FOR
MONEY AND SO THAT MONEY GETS
LEFT ON THE TABLE AND IT'S
REALLY THAT'S AN UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION SO SUMMIT IS VERY
CONCRETE SOME OF IT IS MORE.
HOW DO YOU TELL YOUR STORY HOW
DO YOU -- WHO DO YOU ADVOCATE
WITH HOW DO YOU BUILD STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS -- I AGAIN CHECK
HELD AT AT AT THE THINK THE
POINTED THAT.
YOU MADE MADAM CHAIR ABOUT MULTI
YEAR FUNDING IS THIS WAS IS
REALLY IS A CRITICAL POINT --
AGAIN GOING BACK TO MY MY
EARLIER PITCH ABOUT A PARTICULAR
SMALLER NONPROFITS PLAN FOR
GRANT YOU HAVE TO DO THAT EVERY
YEAR AT THAT.
GETS TO BE VERY EXPENSIVE BUT IF
YOU CAN PUT A GRANT TOGETHER
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD -- IT
IT'S IT'S SPREAD SPREADS THE THE
PAIN OF A BIT MORE SO I THINK
THAT.
IS CRITICAL PLUS IT ALLOWS --
THESE NONPROFITS TO MAINTAIN OF
AN APPOINTMENT BASIS AND AND
PROVIDE THE SERVICES WITH SOME
CONSISTENCY -- I THINK THE OTHER
OTHER POINT IS IS COLLABORATION --
THE MHS ALWAYS CS MENTAL
HEALTH'S OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION IS A
LONG AFTERNOON -- WITH THAT
MENTAL HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM FUN
ADVOCACY -- REGIONAL DUCATION
SEVEN OR EIGHT STAKEHOLDER THAT
RECEIVE GRANTS AND QUARTERLY WE
MADE -- AS A GROUP AND AND AND
TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING THE GRANT AND THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO IT BECOME
MORE EFFECTIVE.
AND IT IN THE WHOLE RANGE OF
MENTAL SERVICES LGBTQ COMMUNITY
PERRANCE VETERANS -- AND
ENSURING THAT INFORMATION I
THINK HELPS -- ALL OF THE
NONPROFITS IMPLEMENT THOSE
GRANTS MORE EFFECTIVELY BUT ALSO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO BECOME MORE
EFFICIENT AND MORE EFFECTIVE.
THANK YOU.
SO I THINK WITH THE WHAT OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITY HAS DONE IS
IT'S BEEN SO DIFFERENT IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW INITIALLY PROVIDING.
LISTENING TO THE COMMUNITY -- ON
WHAT THEY NEED -- WHETHER IT'S
FOR SERVICE SOARED AS A NON
PROFIT HOW CAN THEY DELIVER THAT
SERVICE I THINK -- THAT'S BEEN
WONDERFUL THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS BEEN EXCELLENT AND
THEN FLEXIBILITY AND ALSO
LISTENING TO EACH PARTICULAR
NONPROFIT AS TO WHAT THEY NEED.
IN TERMS OF THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
OR OR OR IN TERMS OF THEIR NEEDS
AS A COMMUNITY I THINK ALL OF
THAT OFFICE ABOUT HOW
HEALTHEQUITY HAS BEEN DOING AND
IT'S BEEN -- JUST VERY BEAUTIFUL
I THINK -- BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT.
I I THINK AS A SMALL NONPROFIT
WHEN YOU HAVE NOT RECEIVED
FUNDING BEFORE AND THEN YOU
RECEIVE.
ONE OF HAVING.
OF HAVING THE THE THE CASH FLOW
TO BE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S
MORE REIMBURSABLE INVOICING.
THAT PART IS IS DIFFICULT -- AND
SO -- LEARNING HOW TO MANAGE
THAT AND MATCHING IT AND SO
FORTH I THINK THAT'S ONE
CHALLENGE FOR NONPROFITS WHO'D
NEVER HAD FUNDING -- I HOPE I'M
CLEAR IN WHAT I'M TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE HERE BUT I THINK
THAT'S A ONE MAJOR -- THING THAT
I THINK WOULD BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL IF IF THERE'S A WAY TO
ALLEVIATE THAT FOR FIRST SMALL
NON PROFITS -- BUT OF THIS KIND
OF PIGGY BACK OF WHAT I THINK
EVERYONE'S PRETTY MUCH SAID
THINK MULTI YEAR GRANTS ARE ARE
ARE HUGE IT REDUCES THE THE
TURNOVER AND IT ALLOWS FOR SOME
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE IN THE
IN THE IN THE NONPROFIT SAN IN
ANYWHERE -- I THINK FOR IN THE
VETERAN COMMUNITY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
FOR THE SERVICE ADVISORS TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THE
VETERANS AND I THINK IF THERE'S
A LARGE TURNOVER THAT YOU'RE
GONNA KINDA LOSE THAT INTEREST
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE OF OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
COMMUNITY.
IT'S CHANGING DAY TODAY I THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE OUTSIDE
PROBABLY MINUSES ROOM.
THINK THE VETERAN COMMUNITY IS
IS GET GROWING IT'S GOING HIGHER
OR LARGER THE CHECK TO GETTING
SMALLER -- BECAUSE THE VIETNAM
ERA WORLD WAR -- TWO THERE
ANOTHER PASSING AWAY SO THE
NEEDS ARE DIFFERENT IT'S AGING
KIND OF RIGHT NOW BUT IT'S ALSO
MENTAL HEALTH AT THE SAME TIME I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AT THE
NONPROFIT CAN UNDERSTAND.
THE NEEDS OF THE VETERANS.
RIGHT AND FINALLY MY LAST
QUESTION IS -- BUT YEAH IT'S A
LONG LINES I THINK OF OF WHAT
I'VE BEEN.
ED JUST IT KIND OF MENTIONING OF
YOU'VE GIVEN US IDEAS OF THINGS
THAT COULD BE CHANGED ARE THERE
ANY -- KIND OF LAST THOUGHT THAT
YOU WANT TO LEAVE WITH A
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN TERMS OF THE
WORK YOU DO AND AND ELEMENTS
THAT WE SHOULD KEEP IN MIND NOT
JUST AS YOU KNOW WE'RE MOVING
LEGISLATION FORWARD BUT AS FOR
CRAFTING LEGISLATION AS WELL.
AND USE SHARED DEFINITELY VERY
PRACTICAL THINGS THAT IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE FOR MORE OF A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE.
AND NOW WHEN I GUESS IN MENTAL
HEALTH AS WELL GIVEN WATER THE
WORD SERVICE DELIVERY SMALL NON
PROFITS I AM THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BRINGING UP THE POINT ABOUT
THEIR INABILITY.
WE CAN'T GIVE MONEY FOR
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T ALREADY
HAPPENED.
THE STATE CANNOT GRANT ST MONEY
FOR SOMETHING HAS ALREADY
HAPPENED.
THAT IS A HUGE BARRIER TO
GETTING SMALL NONPROFITS EITHER
EXPANDING OR DOING SOMETHING NEW
BECAUSE THEY'RE RUNNING RIGHT
CLOSE TO THEIR BASE LINE IF WE
WERE ABLE TO GIVE.
MONEY TO GET THEM TO START UP
FUNDING AND ACTUALLY START FOR
RECEIVING SERVICES.
WHICH EITHER COULD BE PAY BACK
OR YOU KNOW SO IN OTHER WORDS IT
DON'T IT AS IT ABOUT POSTS ARE
SAYING.
OKAY GO AHEAD.
EXPAND YOUR SERVICES WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU ANY MONEY UNTIL YOU
BILL US FOR THOSE SERVICES YOU
CAN'T HIRE PEOPLE ON A PROMISE
THAT YOU'LL PAY THEM LATER --
AND THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT
WE'RE ASKING NON PROFITS TO DO
AND I THINK FOR SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS IN PARTICULAR THAT
DON'T CARRY A LARGE AMOUNT OF OF
MONEY IN THE BANK.
IT'S IT ACTUALLY CAN BE A GAME
AND I WAS -- TAKEN BY ONE OF THE
EARLIER --COMMENTS THAT WAS
MADE IN THE IN THE FIRST PANEL
ABOUT HOW LARGE THE NONPROFIT --
COMMUNITY IS AND IN CALIFORNIA
IT SURPRISED ME I HAD NO IDEA
WHAT ONE IN -- SEVEN AND AND I
THINK THAT.
IT JUST IT JUST BRINGS TO MIND
THE IMPORTS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND AND THE WORK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE DOES BECAUSE OF ITS
THAT LARGE A SEGMENT OF OUR OUR
ECONOMY OF OUR OUR BY OUR WORK
FORCE -- WE CERTAINLY ARE PAYING
ENOUGH ATTENTION TO IT.
ANNA AND I THINK THAT THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE HEARING
HIGHLIGHTING THAT IS IMPORTANT
AND I THINK JUST IT NEEDS WE
NEED MORE OF THAT WE NEED.
MORE OF AN UP THE NONPROFIT OR
THE MONEY TO RUN AROUND TELL
EVERYBODY WE'RE DOING A GREAT
JOB -- AND SO.
THIS IS FREE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO DO THAT WE APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SO -- I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
WITH.
A PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FOUR IN MY PREVIOUS
POSITIONS AND THEN IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE WHEN -- OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY WAS STARTING THE
PHASE ONE AND PHASE TO PHASE ONE
AND AND ALSO ON A PERSONAL LEVEL
I AM I AM FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
I'VE GONE TO THE WHOLE REFUGEE
PROCESS WHEN I WAS A CHILD.
AND SO -- I THINK WITH THAT SAID --
WE NEED TO JUST FOCUS MORE ON
LISTENING. TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE IN NEED IN WITHIN THESE
NONPROFITS IN TERMS OF WHAT
WORKS FOR THEM TO HELP THEM HEAL
AND TO LIVE A LIFE OF WILDNESS.
AND I THINK -- OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY HAS BEEN ONE OF THE FEW
THAT PROBABLY THE ONLY ONE WHO'S
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT -- BECAUSE
IT IS SO IMPORTANT AND THEIR
NAMING TO COMMUTE TO FIND
PRACTICE -- BUT IT IS IT'S SO
CRITICAL TO TO TO TO CURE A
COMMUNITY YOU NEED.
TO ASK THEM WHAT IS IT THAT
WORKS FOR YOU AND MANY TIMES IT
IS NOT ONLY THE SERVICE -- BUT
ALSO THE CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
MEANS -- THAT MANY TIMES ARE
JUST OVERLOOKED -- AND AND THE
TRUST AND SO I THINK -- I THINK
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT TO THINK ABOUT -- AND
IN TERMS OF GETTING NOT ONLY
THESE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
BUT NON PROFITS THAT SERVE THESE
COMMUNITIES -- TO TO SUPPORT THE
MORE ENABLE THEM IN THESE AREAS
THANK YOU.
AND ON THE STATE GOVERNMENT SIDE --
THAT CALVET CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH A NON PROFITS BECAUSE OF
AMEND THIS WERE DEFERRED MANY
TIMES TODAY FLEXIBILITY THEY'RE
ABLE TO WORK THE ELIGIBILITY OF
THE PROGRAM'S IS -- A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT THEY'RE THEY'RE ABLE
TO WORK FASTER AT CERTAIN TIMES --
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAL
BUT WE CAN'T BE EVERYWHERE ALL
THE TIME SO WE KNOW WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE BUT WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH NON PROFITS
IS.
IS -- FORCE MULTIPLIER FOR US
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU AND I QUE DESCRIBED AS
FORCE MULTIPLIER.
THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU ALL FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO BE HERE WITH --
US -- TODAY WE VERY MUCH VALUE --
THE FEEDBACK AND THE THOUGHT
THAT YOU'VE SHARED WITH US THANK
YOU.
WE DO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT TO AND THIS WOULD BE THE
TIME WHERE WE WELCOME YOU.
AND TO THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
THIS I'M JENNIFER FEARING THE
SACRAMENTO ADVOCATE FOR COUNT ON
PROFITS AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL TO YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS COMMITTEE -- AND FRANKLY
THROUGH THE WHOLE HOST OF
LEGISLATION THAT YOU KERRY THAT
SPEAKS TO THAT NEEDS OF OF
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND I
THINK WE HEARD A LOT OF REALLY
GREAT IDEAS TODAY AND I CLEARLY
HEARD YOUR CALL TO ACTION FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF KIND OF
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AND
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL TAKE THAT
BACK AND CONSULT WITH OUR TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS --
ORGANIZATIONS ON THAT POINT I
DID WANT TO JUST POP UP TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUR COMMENT
ABOUT THE NEED FOR MORE ADVOCACY
TRAININGS AND JUST TO MAKE SURE
SPACE REASON SOME PEOPLE ARE ARE
STREAMING IN WATCHING THIS
ONLINE. TO BE AWARE THAT THIS
HAS COME UP TO SUCH AN EXTENT
THAT COUNT ON PROFITS HAS BEEN
PLEASED TO BE PARTNERING ALREADY
THIS YEAR WITH NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE PUT ON TO
VERY WELL ATTENDED.
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY TRAININGS WE
HAD OUR FIRST IN LOS ANGELES
THAT SEND SENATOR MITCHELL JOIN
US FOR THE OTHER OR CLOSE TO A
HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS THERE AND
THEN JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE
WERE IN STOCKTON WITH MAYOR TUBS.
AND SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
SUPERVISOR MILLER ANOTHER
DIVERSE ARRAY OF NONPROFIT
LEADERS IN THAT COMMUNITY TO
REALLY BREAK DOWN THE NUTS AND
BOLTS OF OF WHAT THEY'RE ALLOWED
TO DO WITH IT BUT THE VALUE OF
ENGAGING IN ADVOCACY AND HEARING
FROM ELECTED LEADERS IN THAT
SPACE ABOUT.
HOW MUCH THEY WANTED TO HEAR
FROM?
THAT FROM THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY ABOUT THEIR NEEDS AND
ABOUT THEIR POLICY IDEAS IT WAS
DEVON REALLY TRANSFORMATIVE
EXPERIENCES WE HAVE. TWO MORE
PLANNED IN TWENTY NINETEEN ONE
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THEN ONE
ON THE NORTH COAST AND WE ARE
HEARING OF A STRONG CALL 424-
HOLDING MORE OF THOSE NO WE HAD
ONE AND THAT WAS HOSTED IN YOUR
COMMUNITY AND SANTA BARBARA LAST
YEAR IN THERE.
IT SEEMS TO BE A STRONG THIRST
WITHIN THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
TO UNDERSTAND THIS MORE SO WE
WANT TO TRY TO MEET THAT.
AND I GUESS I'LL JUST QUOTE
WANTED TO CLOSE BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THE ENTHUSIASM WE HAVE THAT OUR
GOVERNOR HAS RECENTLY APPOINTED --
A NEW SENIOR ADVISER ON TO
SERVICE SORT OF A BRIDGE BETWEEN
THE STATE AND THE PHILANTHROPIC
AND NONPROFIT COMMUNITY AND
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THAT SIGNAL
SORT OF SIMILAR TO THE CREATION
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
IT SHOWS A REALLY A SIGIFICANT
GROWTH AT THE STATE LEVEL OF
ENGAGING THIS SIGNIFICANT SECTOR
THAT REALLY WE REALLY HAVE HAD A
HARD TIME PREVIOUSLY FIGURING%
OUT HOW TO ACCESS -- THAT POLICY
ARENA SO GRATEFUL TO BOTH THE
GOVERNOR AND I HOPE YOU'LL
YOU'LL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IT
CONNECT -- WITH -- KATHLEEN.
HAS TAKEN ON THAT ROLE AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN WHAT WE CAN DO
TOGETHER ABSOLUTELY I THINK THAT
THAT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY.
TO CONNECT AND KIND OF EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE DO AND I
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT WITH THAT
CAL NONPROFITS HAS NOW -- A
SCHEDULE OF I'M OF THESE
TRAINING AND WORKSHOPS I WOULD
LOVE TO ASK FOR AT LEAST FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE TO BE SHARED
ONE WITH MYSELF BUT ALSO WITH
THE MEMBERS WHO REPRESENT THE
GENERAL AREA I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT THING.
THAT PERHAPS -- THEY CAN SHARE
WITH THEIR NON PROFITS AS WELL
I'M JUST KNOWING THAT THESE ARE
HAPPENING IN GETTING THE WORD
OUT BECAUSE WE DO AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS GET A LOT OF QUESTIONS
FROM NON PROFITS RELATED. TO
ADVOCACY AND FUNDING AND SO I
THINK WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- THAT THE THE
LEADERS HAVE A WAY TO SAY LOOK
THERE HERE'S A RESOURCE FOR YOU --
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT SO THAT
WOULD BE GREAT SO THANK YOU.
I HEARING NO ADDITIONAL NANA AND
ISSUE DON'T KNOW ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE AGAIN FOR PARTICIPATING
FOR TAKING THE TIME I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A VERY BUSY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THERE'S MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO.
WANTED TO BE HERE BUT WHAT.
COULD NOT EVEN PHYSICALLY ATTEND
BECAUSE OF THE DEMANDS ON THEIR
TIME AT THE MOMENT SO -- IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE CAN WE CONSIDER
VERY IMPORTANT WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS.
SOME OF MY TAKE AWAYS -- ARE
CERTAINLY RELATED TO WHAT THE
STATE CAN -- PERHAPS DUE TO
ALLOW FLEXIBILITY TO ALSO FOCUS
ON THE SMALLER NONPROFIT TO HAVE
A DIFFERENT TOUCH ON A A YOU
KNOW WITHIN THEIR THEIR
COMMUNITY -- AT AS WELL AS
REALLY FOCUSING ON SOME OF THE
GREATER ISSUES THAT CANNOT BE
SOLVED A THING TODAY -- BY THE
STATE ALONE -- MENTAL HEALTH IS
ONE OF THE THE THE ISSUES THAT
DESPITE.
SO MANY MEMBERS KNOWING HOW BIG
OF A CONCERN IT IS IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE WE STILL FEEL LIKE
WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH -- AS A
STATE AND A THINK THAT WE WE
HEAR OF OF SOME OF SOME OF THESE
AREAS WHERE THE FUNDING IS GOING
THAT IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE AND
THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL FOR US TO
HEAR -- BUT ALSO TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WE CAN'T DO IT ALONE AND
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO PARTNER
WITH OTHER ENTITIES WITH OTHER
OTHER.
YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT ENTITIES OR
NON PROFITS AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
NONPROFITS REALLY HAVE PICKED UP
SOME OF THE PIECES WHERE THE
STATE IS NOT ABLE TO PICK UP SO.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING AND FOR ENGAGING
IN THIS DISCUSSION I HOPE THAT
THOSE OF YOU WATCHING ONLINE --
ALSO ENJOYED THE DISCUSSION AS
MUCH AS WE DID AND I DO HOPE
THAT THOSE WATCHING ONLINE OR
THOSE AT THAT PARTICIPATING ANY
OTHER WAY THAT STILL HAVE
COMMENTS WILL REACH OUT TO US
EVEN AS COMMITTEE CHAIR WE WANT
TO KEEP HEARING FROM FOLKS ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT.
WE CAN DO -- IT TO HELP
NONPROFITS BAD BETTER SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO HELP THE FOURTH
LARGEST INDUSTRY IN OUR STATE.
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU AGAIN